1. Null
2. Null
3. Null
4. Null
5. Null
6. Null
7. Null
So, auf geht's, dreimal dürft ihr raten, wo ich gerade gewesen bin.
Nein, ich lese nicht, ich habe auf dem Klo keinen Chat gelesen.
Und ich war auch nicht auf dem Klo, ich habe mir noch was zu trinken geholt.
So, ich habe mal wieder Zeit, muss ein bisschen was einkaufen.
Ich mache meistens den Stream an, dann fällt mir ein, ich brauche noch was zu trinken und dann flitze ich schnell runter.
Habe ich eigentlich schon mal erwähnt, nein, ich wollte euch nicht meine Heizung zeigen.
Habe ich schon mal erwähnt, wie sehr mir Microsoft Teams auf den Keks geht.
Jedes Mal, ich meine, das habe ich schon total oft erzählt und ich habe noch keine sinnvolle Lösung gefunden.
Jedes Mal, ja Slack ist besser, das bringt mir jetzt nichts.
Ich kann es mir ja nicht aussuchen.
Bringst auch geil, dass hier das Mikrofon kaum ausschlägt und hier ist es voll.
Windows Logging muss man nicht verstehen.
Was ist deine Lieblingspizza? Hat es seit 2, das sagt.
Das ist richtig, feels Batman.
Ich habe mittlerweile nur noch 2 Lieferdienste, wo ich bestellen kann.
Die I am Jinxed, 3 Monate, danke schön.
Exquisite Subscription.
Big Brain, ich kann nur noch 2 Lieferdienste bestellen und zwar bei allen anderen hatte ich bisher immer irgendwas.
Bei diesem einen Pizza in der Schnitzelladen, die haben irgendwie alles, da kann ich nicht mehr bestellen.
Weil da hatte ich mal beim Salat irgendwas drin, wo es mir schlecht war danach.
Das letzte Mal habe ich euch ja erzählt, wo ich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben eine meldepflichtige Krankheit hatte.
Und nein, es hat nichts damit mit Corona zu tun.
Da habe ich entweder bei meinem Dönerladen um die Ecke gegessen oder bei einem italienischen Lieferservice, wo ich mir einen Rahmenschnitzel bestellt habe mit Salat.
Eins von beiden war es, warum ich diesen Mist bekommen habe.
Ja, meldepflichtig. Ich wusste auch nicht, dass die Krankheit meldepflichtig ist, bis ich ein Brief vom Gesundheitsamt bekommen habe,
dass das Labor, wo ich meine Probe abgegeben habe, dass die ans Gesundheitsamt gemeldet haben.
Ich wusste auch nicht, dass das, ich habe ja schon mal gezeigt, was das war.
Bacter, Bacter, ist auch egal. Irgendwas, wo man haltet und Schiss von kriegt und Bauchweh und Fieber und so.
Ich hatte glaube ich bis zu 39,4 oder so Fieber, also es war wirklich nicht ohne.
Nicht Salmonellen, nein nein, es war nicht Salmonellen, es geht aber in die gleiche Richtung, sowas in der Richtung war das.
Irgendwas mit Campylobacter, das klingt gut, das klingt gut.
Slim Ontario, das klingt gut, ja das war es glaube ich.
Was ist dein Lieblingsdeskription, Desktop Environment?
Das sage ich gleich, ich muss gerade noch kurz das hier fertig erzählen.
Da war es halt auch so, ich habe bei meinem Dönerladen bestellt und ich habe bei so einem italienischen Lieferservice Rahmschnitzel und Salat bestellt.
Eins davon war es, 100 pro, da bin ich mir extrem sicher.
Ich habe das auch gleich ans Gesundheitsamt gemeldet, wahrscheinlich steht jetzt einer bei denen auf der Matte demnächst.
So und das war echt unangenehm, das könnt ihr mir glauben.
Wie bin ich denn jetzt darauf gekommen?
Genau, aus irgendwelchen Sekunden bin ich von Teams auf Dünnschiss gekommen, habe ich nicht.
Komische Gedankengänge, die mir dann manchmal durch den Kopf gehen.
Zumindest Teams an sich ist ja gar nicht so schlecht, aber was mir bei Teams mega auf den Keks geht und gegen, mag ja sein, dass manche Leute sagen Matrix, Slack, Rocket, Chat, Discord, was auch immer ist alles besser.
Aber ich kann halt nichts daran ändern, wenn die auf der Arbeit Teams verwenden.
So und jedes Mal, wenn ich Teams telefoniert habe, muss ich das hier zurückstellen.
Teams macht das immer hier volle Pulle auf Anschlag, dann hört sich das mal mega beschissen an.
So richtig kacke hört sich das dann an.
So, aber wenn ich das runter mache, dann ist viel, viel besser, aber Teams furtelt da immer dran rum.
Ganz, ganz furchtbar abartig und ich habe halt wirklich keine Ahnung, wie ich das Teams abgewöhnen kann.
Ich hatte schon die Idee, ich programmiere mir irgendwas, was immer Hardcoded, die Mikrophone Input auf 71 setzt.
Warum muss einem Teams eigentlich immer eine Mail schicken, wenn man Nachrichten abwesend bekommen hat?
Ich frage mich viele, Skype for Business hat das auch immer gemacht.
Teams mittlerweile macht das nur, wenn man ausgelockt war.
So, aber jetzt mal zu der eigentlichen Frage, die eben hier gekommen ist. Ah ne, habe ich gar nicht hier drin.
Was meine Lieblingsdistribution und Desktop Environment ist.
Meine Lieblingsdistribution auf dem Desktop, stimmt mal darum geht es ja auch, ist eindeutig Manjaro.
Lieblings Desktop Environment ist gar kein Desktop Environment, sondern einfach nur i3WM, weil Desktop verwende ich eh nicht.
Also so den Desktop, sowas hier mit Icons und so verwende ich eh nicht.
Deswegen sind hier auch die ganzen Icons vom Stream drauf.
Ne, also wie gesagt, ich verwende i3WM und da ist ja keinerlei Desktopgeschichten dabei.
Ich habe eigentlich alles im Fullscreen.
Kannst du hier drauf reaken, PS5 tier down? Ja heute nicht, heute nicht.
Vielleicht nachher, vielleicht wenn wir fertig einkaufen sind.
Vor allem, ich mache es mir mal auf, vielleicht können wir das nachher wirklich machen.
Vielleicht können wir das nachher gucken, aber jetzt nicht.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal uns ein wenig dem Konsum hingeben.
Aber ich brauche ein paar spezielle Sachen.
Ich glaube heute ist gar nicht mal so viel Banggood und AliExpress, also nicht so viel Banggood,
sondern wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Amazon und mal gucken, wo ich sonst noch ein paar andere Sachen bekomme.
Ich muss gerade mal in den Einkaufskorb gucken, was ich da noch alles drin habe vom letzten Mal.
Okay, das muss ich auf jeden Fall noch bestellen.
Wie war eigentlich deine Bilanz von Fancy Zones, so dass ich schon gar nicht mehr genau weiß, was es ist?
Das war eben etwas, was bei Power Toys dabei war.
Power Tools, Power Toys, wie heißt es?
Pussy schreibt, hätte gestern fast zwei Nux gekauft, damit ich meine Server ablösen kann.
Echt, ich finde die Nux gar nicht so gut, was das anbelangt.
Hauptsächlich, weil du halt keinerlei Erweiterungsmöglichkeiten hast.
Also was mir halt fehlt, ist der PizziExpress-Slot, den man immer irgendwie gebrauchen kann.
Bilder von mir werden im Discord gezeigt.
So, so, ganz bestimmt ist das hier Huge Massive Gebate.
Das ist doch Exzellent. Tja, das funktioniert nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Keine Chance, weil ich habe eine Vorschau, da gehe ich über den Link drüber.
Und dann sehe ich, was hinter dem Link ist.
Und da habe ich gerade irgendwie Tarek Discord Einladung oder so gesehen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, nein, da werden bestimmt keine Bilder von mir gezeigt.
Bspwm gearbeitet.
Es kann sein, dass ich es mal kurz ausprobiert habe.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin mit i3wm so glücklich, was das angeht.
Das ist fast in der, also es ist eine der wenigen Software, die ich verwende.
Mit fast, fast Default Settings.
Oh, das müsste ich euch jetzt mal zeigen.
Mein Avira auf meinem zweiten, ich habe da immer noch Avira drauf, frag mich nicht warum.
Ich bin ja der Meinung, eigentlich brauchen wir gar keine Viren Scanner.
Aber ich habe da seit Jahren Avira drauf und irgendwie habe ich nie den installiert.
Zumindest ist mein Avira jetzt der Meinung.
6 Issues Detected. Review Now.
So und jetzt klicke ich das mal an.
Und jetzt kommt was, was eigentlich schon, ich gucke mal ob ich euch, wartet mal,
ich gucke mal ob ich euch irgendwie einen Screenshot oder so zeigen kann.
Weil das, da kommen wir jetzt wirklich in Bereiche, wo Antivirus, ja hier guckt mal.
Wo Antivirus quasi zur Malware oder nicht zur Malware, aber zur, wie nennt man das?
Scareware, ach frag mich nicht, was auch immer wird.
Davon ist nichts Schlimmes, nichts.
Es sind 14 Outdated Adware, genau guck mal.
Es sind 14 Outdated Apps, who cares?
Es ist Windows.
So, dann sind irgendwie Browser Cookies.
Oh nein, Browser Cookies, ganz, ganz furchtbar schlimm.
Dann gibt es irgendwie Privacy Settings und man kann Zeug aufhören.
Was da dran ist jetzt genau gefährlich?
Also mal ernsthaft, jetzt frage ich die jetzt mal auf Twitter.
Was genau da dran gefährlich ist?
Avira Spam.
Weil was genau soll da dran gefährlich sein?
Ist das jetzt schlimm?
Zehn Slow Startup Apps.
Was genau möchte Avira da dran ändern, wenn die Dinger schnell langsam starten?
Ja, das stimmt schon hier.
Die Sache ist nur die, dass dieses Popup kommt, nachdem man unten rechts von Avira angezeigt bekommen hat,
dass Probleme auf dem System gefunden werden, die man jetzt beheben kann.
Das ist halt schon ein bisschen die Leute verarscht.
Es kam nämlich gerade ein Popup, Probleme auf ihrem Rechner gefunden,
Review Issues, zack, das ist dann Gebaided Scam.
Ich muss übrigens mal kurz durch den Chat gucken.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht, gar nicht geschaut.
So, wen haben wir denn hier alles am Start?
Die üblichen Verdächtigen sind wieder am Start.
Mark, Jojo, ich lese immer noch Yolo, frag mich nicht warum.
Der Patrick ist da, Flo690, G-Pad, Captain Peng, Flo690 hat sich gefragt, ob ich gerade auf dem Klo war.
Tja, nee, war ich nicht.
Wichtig, das ist natürlich, das ist eine Frage, die interessiert den Chat immer wieder.
Phipps ist auch da, Kuzee ist da, Venden, Niko, CS, Clox, HD Tribulon, Herz93, Kingwall.
Die üblichen Verdächtigen, ich sehe schon wieder hier.
Kingwall hat sein Abo verlängert, exzellent.
Teams in einer Sandbox ausführen vielleicht, das ist wahrscheinlich dann problematisch mit Zugriff auf Kamera.
Kamera ist ein gutes Thema, ich muss mir eine billige Webcam kaufen für Teams, weil ich keinen Bock habe immer das iPhone vor mich zu stellen.
Gibt es da irgendwelche billige Kackwebcams, so für 5 Euro?
Irgendwie so billige Logitechwebcam oder sowas da?
Irgendwas richtig, richtig mieses, was für Teams reicht.
Ich meine, bei mir bekommen die Leute im Teams schon mal High Quality Audio.
Das ist ja schon mal was, was ich bei den meisten Leuten nicht bekomme.
Deswegen muss das dann vom Bild her nicht so gut sein.
C2HO, das habe ich ausprobiert, das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Du meinst, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Das habe ich ausprobiert.
Hier, das da.
Exclusive gibt es hier irgendwo.
Es gibt hier irgendwo so ein Setting Exclusive, das habe ich ausprobiert, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Dann hat Eikin gefragt, hey Max, nimmst du bei billigen AliExpress Kabel Newcreen oder hast du einen anderen Favoriten?
Also Kabel bestelle ich bei AliExpress weniger.
Also ich glaube, die einzigen Kabel, die ich bei AliExpress bestellt habe, waren, ich finde es jetzt nicht mehr, diese USB Kabel.
Ich habe mal so ein 50er Pack USB Kabel bestellt und das waren so eine Kiste voll und das waren No Name Kabel.
Aber ich meine, immerhin zwei Meter USB auf USB C und Mikro USB und 50 Stück inklusive Versand für unter 50 Euro.
Das heißt, ich habe irgendwie 80 Cent für ein Kabel bezahlt, also das ist halt schon echt billig.
Generell, ich kann jedem nur ans Herz legen, kauft euer Zeug, also man muss keine Bedenken haben, so ein Zeug in China zu kaufen.
So Elektro-Kram, was ich nicht unbedingt in China kaufen würde, ist jetzt vielleicht ein Kühlschrank oder sowas.
Aber ansonsten, ihr könnt ohne Bedenken die Sachen in China kaufen.
Weil viele Sachen, die ihr bei Amazon findet und sucht und kauft, zum Beispiel irgendwelche Mehrfach-Steckdosen und sonst was, das ist zum größten Teil auch China-Kram.
Nur, dass da noch irgendwie einer 5 Euro dran verdient.
Moin Liko.
Hast du mittlerweile schon ein Mikro HDMI Kabel? Hab ich, ja.
Schau mal den allgemeinen Channel, mach ich nachher.
Ich bin gerade noch nicht so weit im Chat, ich muss gerade mal Chat durchscrollen.
Genau Patrick, sehe ich auch so. Er schreibt, die Idee vom Pop-Up ist aber eindeutig hier.
Die Idee vom Pop-Up ist aber eindeutig. Um ein bisschen Angst zu machen, eine Vollversion zu verkaufen, exakt genau das.
Also im Prinzip das, was irgendwelche Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner auch machen, nur halt ein bisschen extremer.
Aber es gibt ja, oh ne, bleibt das jetzt wieder nicht oben.
Es gibt ja auch genug Viren, die nichts Schlimmes machen, aber halt zu tun, als wäre was, dass sie Leute kaufen.
Die haben ja kein Interesse, den Rechner kaputt zu machen, weil wenn sie den Rechner kaputt machen, dann können sie den, also richtig kaputt machen, dann können sie den Leuten keine Angst mehr machen.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Der Helmauf fragt, ich frag mich, ob sich ein langes USB-C Kabel vom Computer zum Wohnzimmer lohnt, um dort Content auf einem TV direkt vom Computer abzuspielen.
Ansonsten hat sich sowas wie ein... Warum nicht?
Du kannst ja auch ein langes HDMI-Kabel holen. Nur warum nicht? Warum nicht? Ja.
Ich finde halt, der Vorteil ist von sowas wie einem Shield-TV oder einem Fire-TV oder sowas, der Vorteil ist halt, dass du es gut mit der Fernbedienung bedienen kannst.
Und dass das Android-TV halt auch App-Versorgungstechnisch und auch mit Hinblick auf Bedienen über Fernbedienung ausgelegt ist.
Und dass gerade für Noobs, die technisch nicht so versiert sind, machbar ist, also einfacher machbar ist, als irgendwelche Sachen am Computer zu starten.
Also meine Mutter wird es beispielsweise nicht gebacken bekommen. Da irgendwie Fullscreen-Code am PC oder so. Die braucht da Android-TV oder irgendwas mit Fernbedienung dreimal draufdrücken und der Scheiß funktioniert.
Tribolon, das ist eine sehr gute Idee, aber ich kann mir nicht die fette Kinect oben auf den Monitor legen. Und was ist mit Schweißgerät auf AliExpress kaufen?
Hey, ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich mir nicht so ein 250 Euro CNC-Ding mal auf AliExpress bestellen soll, einfach weil es geht.
Da gibt es richtig coole Dinge. Ich habe davon halt keine Ahnung, aber wenn ich jetzt schon 3D-Drucker habe, ich wollte es mal ausprobieren.
Kostet glaube ich nur 200 Dollar oder so. Könnte man mal ausprobieren.
Was ist das? Kann man das aufmachen?
Ok, es ist Amazon. Das kann nicht so schlimm sein. Achso, du meinst das sogar ernst. Da kommt jetzt irgendwie eine Kamera mit, frag mich nicht, Anime-Kissen dabei oder so.
Schön mit Ref-Link erstmal. Exquisite. Nee, ist gar nicht mit Ref-Link, oder? Ah, wenn ich sehe, ja.
So, wunderbar. Äh, übrigens da noch eine Sache. Warum HDMI sogar, wer hat das hier geschrieben?
Was da nicht verkehrt ist, eventuell lohnt es sich, HDMI vom Rechner an den Fernseher zu machen, weil es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man über HDMI, wahrscheinlich auch über Display-Porter weiß ich nicht genau,
dass man dort, wenn der Fernseher einen Empfänger hat für Remote-Signale, dann kann man das über, ich glaube CEC heißt das, also sprich, die Kamera sendet Signale an den Fernseher und der Fernseher kann über HDMI die Signale zurück an den Rechner schicken.
Also sprich, der Fernseher empfängt die Remote-Signale, die dann auf seinem Rechner Dinger machen. Vielleicht ist sogar ein HDMI-Kabel für dich besser als ein USB-Kabel zu legen, vom, ins Wohnzimmer.
Doch, doch, Display-Port hat auch Ton. Würde mich zumindest sehr wundern, wenn es das nicht hat, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass Display-Port auch Ton hat.
So, jetzt habe ich den Chat durch, exellent. So, dann fangen wir mal an. Und zwar, ich hatte, ich hatte, also erstens muss ich euch nochmal was erzählen. Nee, Moment, bevor ich euch was erzähle, muss ich erstmal durchgucken, was ich hier von drinnen behalten muss im wahren Korb vom letzten Mal.
Ein Moin, das Ebaro ist auch da. Cute-Mod. Enter's Chat. So, also die Dinger, woops. Die Dinger bestelle ich mir auf jeden Fall. Das ist was richtig, richtig geiles.
Das habe ich letztens wieder im Video gesehen. Das ist wirklich Big Brain. Das sind Gewinde. Also zum Beispiel, man druckt sich mit seinem 3D-Drucker was aus und man möchte das Teil irgendwo dran befestigen und man möchte dort irgendwie eine Scheibe drauf schrauben, irgendwas.
Dann hast du ja das Problem, dass Löcher für Schrauben, die du mit dem 3D-Drucker ausdruckst, die sind halt kacke. Da kannst du ein, zwei Mal was rein und rausschrauben, dann geht es nicht mehr. So, und das sind Gewinde. Die setzt du ans Plastik an und dann hältst du ein Lötkolben dran.
Und dadurch, dass die mit dem Lötkolben heiß werden, schmelzen die sich in das Plastik rein und bilden dann quasi, bleiben dann feststecken und mal gucken, ob es dann ein Video zugibt. Wie nennen sich die Dinger eigentlich genau?
So was hier. Ja, 3D-Printing. Mal gucken, ob es da ein Video zugibt. Ah, schauen wir mal. Mal gucken, ob der... Ja, guck mal hier. Ah, Moment. Ich will sehen, wie er das rein macht.
So, da muss man jetzt den Lötkolben dran halten. Passt mal auf, das ist richtig nice. Guck hier, Lötkolben dran und saug, saug, saug. Oder was heißt saugen? Das ist nicht nice.
Wobei, ich habe eine Idee. Kennt ihr diese Videos, die auf YouTube irgendwie machen, Satisfying to watch, diese Satisfying-Videos, wo dann Leute irgendwelche Omelettes in der Pfanne rumdrehen auf einmal oder irgendwelches Eis abkratzen oder so?
Ich glaube, damit könnte man 10 Minuten Videos Satisfying machen, weil ich finde das, weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, ich finde das unglaublich Satisfying, sich anzugucken, wie dieses Ding sich in das 3D-Gedruckte reinschmilzt.
Ultra Satisfying. Ja, und die Dinger sind halt richtig poggers. Und da hält es jetzt halt auch. Hätte der das vorher hier in das Loch geschraubt, wo das was da drunter ist, das wäre noch zweimal kaputt gewesen.
Wisst ihr, was auch richtig geile Videos sind, die ich mir übelst gerne angucke, so zum Einschlafen, das sind so Restaurierungsvideos, wo dann Leute irgendwie, ähm, was weiß ich, verrostetes Messer wieder Plank machen und so.
Und ich meine nicht, 1000 Grad heißes Messer vs. Cola-Flasche, falls da so einer guckt. Max guckt sich bestimmt ASMR Janina an. Nein, die gucke ich nicht an.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin ja mittlerweile auch, also am Anfang habe ich mir immer so gedacht, ja okay, ich fand das, ich finde, fand die meisten ASMR-Dinger teilweise am Anfang übelst verstörend, aber ich habe die falschen Channels erwischt.
Ich hatte dann die Leute, die so irgendwie eine Stunde, eine Stunde Mundgeräusche und Zeug rum gemacht haben und was auch immer für komische Geräusche da gemacht werden.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, was ist das? Aber es gibt, aber es gibt auch durchaus Videos, die man sich anschauen kann.
Und ich gucke mittlerweile eigentlich auch mal ganz gern so zur Entspannung was, aber am liebsten, am liebsten gucke ich mir wirklich an irgendwie einen, so einen, so einen Restoration-Videos.
Ein Löt-Video 31 Minuten, ja das ist doch was gut.
Ja, aber die Dinger sind wirklich massive Poggers. Guckt, ah, das ist so, das ist extrem satisfying to watch, wie gerade die Dinger da reinschmilzt. Guckt euch das mal an, das ist wirklich richtig excellent.
Das könnte ich mir den ganzen Tag angucken.
So, und das hält halt richtig gut. Und Kingwall, ich gebe dir recht, Urin-Restoration kann man sich angucken, wenn die Leute irgendwelche Bilder restaurieren.
Alte, letzte habe ich gesehen, irgendwie einer hat so einen alten Lötkolben restauriert und sowas. Und das finde ich übelst entspannend, da penne ich nach 5 Minuten ein.
Was ich auch gut finde sind so irgendwelche Handwerks-Videos, wo sie dann irgendwie so einen Typ interviewen so nach dem Motto, äh, der letzte, frag mich nicht, der letzte Schuhmacher aus dem hintersten alten Dorf in der Schweiz.
Oder der letzte, der letzte, was, genau, Schuhmacher aus dem letzten Dorf in Österreich. So, interviewen sie irgend so einen, so einen Typ, der seit 60 Jahren das gleiche da macht, der es halt übelst gut kann. Und dann fuddelt der da 45 Minuten in den Balken herum und da ist halt irgendwelche geilen Schuhe fertig.
Also sowas ist auch übelst entspannend. So, was habe ich denn jetzt im Shopping, im Einkaufskorb noch drin, was? Genau, die bestelle ich mir auf jeden Fall.
Ähm, das brauche ich ja auch immer noch, das kaufe ich, kaufe ich wahrscheinlich auch noch, die brauche ich auch noch und die brauche ich auch noch. Okay, das kann ich alles drin lassen, exzellent.
So, und jetzt muss ich euch mal was erzählen. Vor zwei Tagen war extrem Monka-Smoke bei mir in der Wohnung. Also richtig, Monka-Smoke.
Nein, kein Vape Nation Smoke, richtig Smoke, weil mein Toaster ist abgefackelt.
Ich war zum Glück unten und habe das mitgekriegt. Nee, kein Aliexpress Toaster. Wenn es ein Aliexpress Toaster gewesen wäre, dann hätte ich es ja noch verstanden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was für ein Hersteller das ist. Irgendwie ist es auf jeden Fall das. Das war so ein blauer Toaster und ich habe mir so gedacht, was stinkt hier denn so? Ich war gerade im Badezimmer mit der Katze und habe mir gedacht, was stinkt denn hier so?
Da bin ich in die Küche gekommen und habe festgestellt, Alter, der Toaster ist abfackeln. So, Monka-Smoke, alles gelüftet, hat bestimmt eine halbe Stunde gedauert, bis man da wieder rein konnte.
Also ich habe irgendwie insgesamt eineinhalb Stunden alles durchgelüftet und dann ging es wieder. Aber ich überlegte mir gerade, was wäre gewesen, wenn ich da nicht dabei gestanden hätte.
So, und deswegen, ich brauche einen neuen Toaster. Irgendjemand, die neuesten Toaster-Lifehacks und Geheimtipps?
Oh, habe ich den Chat zugemacht? Das ist aber Low-Brain, dass ich den Chat zugemacht habe, Leute. Das sackt auch. Der Umut hat nämlich irgendwas gefragt, und zwar
Hey Max, brauche ich mal deinen Rat? Ich schalte mal kurz hier um. Brauche ich mal deinen Rat? Hab mir einen Laptop gekauft mit einem Warn-LTE-Modul, ok? Also quasi musst du eine SIM-Karte rein machen.
Ich setze die SIM-Karte ein und Windows sagt trotzdem SIM-Karte einlegen, kannst du vielleicht eine Lösung? Also für Windows Problemlösung bin ich echt der Falsche.
Ich hatte weder einen Laptop bisher mit SIM-Karte noch hatte ich dieses Problem unter Windows hier mal. Ich würde als erstes das übliche Problem mit SIM-Karte rauspusten und SIM-Karte wieder rein machen.
Die Krauts, vier Monate, dankeschön. Exquisite-Subscription.
Nice. Subscriber. Und wenn das nicht hilft, würde ich den neuesten Treiber vom Hersteller downloaden und installieren. Und dann hätte ich keine Ahnung mehr, weil ich mir hier Windows nicht auskenne. Nee, da habe ich wirklich keinen Plan.
Ok. Was den hast du dir heute bestellt? Auf Ebay kaufe ich keinen Toaster. Oh, excellent.
Was ist das denn hier? Ernst auf Ebay? The fuck? Was ist mit denen los?
Also erstens, warum kostet der Toaster 400 Dollar? Das ist ein Toaster. Und warum hat der Hersteller so gute Bewertungen?
Das ist bestimmt auch ein Toaster mit SIM-Karte. Was ein Schwachsinn. Ich brauche doch kein Touchscreen. Auf dem Toaster. Gehen wir mal fort.
So. Ok. MB-Dealer. Der wäre jetzt der Toaster-Dealer. Da hätte ich gedacht, der will mir was verkaufen. Aber anscheinend meint er wirklich, dass er sich den hier wirklich gekauft hat. Also den hast du dir gekauft.
Ok. Der Russell Hobbs Colors Digital Coffee Machine. Was? Was hat der Toaster mit Digital Coffee Machine zu tun? Ach, unter dem Produkt gibt es noch mehr. Ach, hier.
Jetzt haben wir trotzdem ziemlich beknackt, wie sie das eingestellt haben bei Amazon, oder? Ach ja, und ich will einen, der zwei Schlitze nebeneinander hat und nicht hintereinander, weil der passt sonst nicht hin an die Stelle, wo er steht.
Ah, excellent. 3000 Euro. Warum ist das so teuer? Sind die noch bei Trost? Ok, was? Die Farbe ändern? Wo? Hier? Wo soll ich die Farbe ändern? Hier?
Ok. Ah, das ist gar nicht so übel. Was ich halt nicht so mag, sind die Toaster, die so komplett aus Metall sind. Da sieht man immer die Fingerabdrücke so sehr drauf. Wobei ich jetzt schlecht einschätzen kann, wie das bei dem ist.
Ok, was kann er? Lift and look exquisite. Ja, also wenn es das gäbe, Airworker, würde ich mir einen Toaster kaufen, wo ich Custom Firmware drauf machen kann.
Oder ich kaufe mir bei AliExpress einen Toaster. Wartet mal, wartet mal, nur mal, nur mal just for fun. Toaster.
Ah, 5 Euro Toaster. Exzellent, das wird bestimmt was Gutes sein. Aus China, ja. Oh, aus Russland 5 Euro, wird ja immer besser. Ah, nur China liefert nach Deutschland.
Das ist ja kein Photoshop, alles echt. Und soll ich euch mal meine ehrliche Einschätzung sagen, ich glaube, dass viele der Dinger, die auf Amazon verkauft werden, die kosten zwar 30 Euro mehr,
aber im Kern ist das der gleiche China-Schrott wie sowas hier. Allerdings, der sieht, also das hier sieht schon echt billig aus.
Also das sieht schon echt billig aus, also der Sache traue ich nicht so ganz. Also das hier sieht wirklich billig aus.
Hat der denn einen Aufsatz für Brötchen? Ich brauche einen Brötchen-Aufsatz. Das brauche ich noch, ich brauche einen Brötchen-Aufsatz.
Nicht so ein komisches Auf, der hat keinen Brötchen-Aufsatz. Ne, nein. 7 Euro Toaster. Oh, guck mal, geht noch billiger. 6 Euro Toaster.
Ok, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie Erfindericht die Chinesen sind. Toaster IOT. Gibt es Internet of Things Toaster? Da fragen wir mal lieber, da fragen wir mal lieber. Ne, gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Da fragen wir mal Google. Gibt es IOT? Wi-Fi-Toaster. Gibt es Wi-Fi-Toaster? The world now has a smart Toaster. Jawoll. Excellent.
Mit Smartphone-App. Leute, ein Gerät ist nicht smart, weil er eine Smartphone-App braucht.
Also, was für 5 Seitenlänge Links gibt es denn da im Chat? Ne, ich werde mal gucken. Also, ich kaufe mir einen, der mit ordentlichem Brötchen-Aufsatz und gut ist.
Aber es gibt kein WLAN-Toaster, der irgendwie Sinn macht anscheinend. Top Smart Wi-Fi-Toasters. Moment, das ist kein Toaster, das ist ein Überbackofen.
Das ist ein Ofen und das ist ein Riesentoaster. Smart Toaster. Yes. Revolution Cooking.
Okay, den hatten wir doch vorhin schon mal. Revolution Cooking R180. Okay, Amazon. Ich will jetzt wissen, was das kostet. Gibt es nicht?
Die was? Toast-Schächten? Ist Schächten nicht, wenn man irgendwelche Ziegen ausbluten lässt? Toast-Schächte. Ach, Toast-Schächte.
4 Schächte für Toastbrot. Jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Aber das ist trotzdem bescheuert geschrieben. Der Bugatti-Toaster. Die sind doch alle nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Cheap Mondo. Ja, also auf einer Seite die Cheap Mondo heißt, kaufe ich natürlich 1.500 Euro Bugatti-Toaster. Alles klar. Cheap Mondo. Klingt schon so vertrauenserweckend.
Was zum Teufel soll das überhaupt sein? Das ist doch kein Toaster. Das sieht aus wie ein Wäschetrockner in klein. Ach so, hier macht man die Toastbrot.
Was ein Schwachsinn. Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, das sieht ja noch nicht mal gut aus. Also man kann sich ja darüber streiten, man für Design oder angenehme Sachen ein bisschen mehr bezahlt. Aber das sieht ja noch mal richtig beschissen aus.
Da war er, da war er. Habt ihr ihn gesehen? Moment, Panzerglasfolie. Folie für den Toaster. Der KitchenAid Artisan. Oh, der Künstler in der Küche.
Ich bestelle mir einen 35 Euro Toaster und gut ist bei Amazon. Alles klar, fertig aus. Vielleicht bestelle ich den Vorschlag hier vom Chet finde ich sogar richtig gut. Die haben einen schönen Brötchenaufsatz, man kann zwischendurch gucken wie braun der Toast ist und passt.
Weißt du was? Bevor ich da jetzt lange rum mache, Bäm. Ich kauf den jetzt einfach. Ist Chet approved? Und der Chet würde mir ja niemals irgendwas empfehlen was nichts taucht, oder?
Dissortion, klar. Alle Reihen Hacker-Ment. Stell dir vor du bestellst Schutzglas für deinen Toaster. Ja, irgendwas stimmt da, stimmt da nicht. Wenn man Schutzfolie für den Toaster braucht.
So, da kommen wir jetzt mal zur eigentlichen Sache. Ich hatte nämlich noch eine weitere Exquisite Big Brain Idee. Zumindest komme ich mir so vor. Wahrscheinlich ist das gar nicht so Big Brain.
Und zwar habe ich folgendes gesehen. Ich habe einen Twitter Post gesehen, wo jemand diese Aquara. Oh Mist, warte mal. Welche Aquara Sensoren waren das? Die da. Die da.
So, ich habe einen Twitter Post gesehen, da hat jemand diese Aquara Sensoren vorgestellt. Was das macht ist folgendes. Das ist ein Vibration Sensor, also ein Sensor der feststellt ob es wackelt.
So was ähnliches habe ich schon mal selbst gebaut mit dem ESP32, nee mit dem ESP62 und einem Brüttelsensor. Also was da drinnen steckt, was da drinnen steckt ist ziemlich billige Technik.
Hier. So, so Dinger. Also es ist nichts tolles was da drinnen steckt. Das ist einfach so kleine, kleine, kleine Dinger die sich bewegen und dadurch erkennt man es. Aber ich hatte eine Idee.
Wofür falls eine Bahn übers Haus fährt? Nee, ich habe mir gedacht was man machen könnte ist folgendes. Und jetzt haltet euch fest, Chat. Man könnte, die Dinger sind ja nicht groß.
Guck mal hier. Guck mal wie klein das ist. Das ist ein Schubler. Das Ding ist wirklich klein. Man könnte das an die Mülltonne machen. Man könnte das an die Mülltonne machen und dann würde man immer mitbekommen wenn die Mülltonne geleert wurde.
Ja in die Mülltonne ist es ein bisschen schwierig, weil in die Mülltonne kommt ja der Müll. Also zum Beispiel ich würde den jetzt nicht unbedingt gerne in die alles Mülltonne hängen.
Aber was sagt ihr zu der Idee? Also man, ich würde das, genau die erste Sache ist, darf man sowas überhaupt an die Mülltonne kleben? Doch, doch ich habe eine Müllkarte, pass mal auf. Ich habe mir das ja schon viel weiter überlegt.
Ich bin ja eigentlich schon einen Schritt weiter, weil ich habe dann auch das hier gefunden. Moment, GitHub, Home Assistant, Garbage Collector. Und ich meine nicht der Garbage Collector.
Ich meine nicht der Garbage Collector. Sondern ich habe einen Home Assistant Frontend Plugin gefunden. Damit kann man sowas machen. So und jetzt habe ich mir das folgendermaßen überlegt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das auf Twitter gelesen und zwar, man macht sich den Müllkalender in seinen Home Assistant rein und dann zeigt er einem an, wann das dran ist.
Und wenn der Müll heute dran ist, dann kann man automatisch eine, ähm, finde ich jetzt gar nicht. Man kann zumindest, wenn heute der Tag dran ist, wo das gelehrt wird, dann kann man mit dem Sensor eine
Funktion hier triggern, die das dann im Web-Interface anzeigt.
Hier, genau. Also sprich, man bekommt auf der einen Seite den Kalender, wenn an dem Tag, wo die Tonne gelehrt wird. Ich stelle das ja am anderen Tag raus auf die Straße.
So, dann interessiert es dir nicht, dass der Rüttelsensor rüttelt. Wenn dann allerdings der Tag ist, wo die Tonne dran ist und der Rüttelsensor hat gerüttelt,
dann ruft er dieses Garbage Collection Collect Garbage Ding auf und dann wird die Tonne im Web-Interface als wurde gelehrt markiert.
Ja, natürlich gibt es dafür feste Termine. Ohne feste Termine würde es ja gar nicht funktionieren.
Du musst dir hier feste Termine eintragen, dass der weiß, wann die Tonne gelehrt wird. Und wenn man die Tonne dann rausgestellt hat und es ist der Tag, wenn die Tonne dran ist und der Rüttelsensor hat gerüttelt,
dann weiß ich, die Müllabfuhr war da oder irgendjemand ist gegen meine Mülltonne gerannt. Also sprich, ich sehe dann, heute ist Mülltonnetag und ich sehe, Mülltonne wurde gelehrt.
Ja, wenn der Sensor aus Versehen auslöst, ist es auch nicht schlimm. Im schlimmsten Fall ist die Tonne halt noch nicht gelehrt.
Ist ja nett zu wissen, aber was hat man denn damit, dass man die Tonne reinholen kann? Habt ihr nie eine Tonne rausgefahren für die Müllabfuhr?
Dem Chat mangelt es an Vorstellungskraft heute. Du stellst die Mülltonne abends raus, dann kriegst du irgendwann eine Nachricht oder siehst im Web-Interface A, die Tonne wurde gelehrt
und dann kannst du rausgehen und die Tonne wieder reinholen. Und du läufst nicht Gefahr, dass du umsonst rausgehst.
Ich mein, umsonst ins Freie gehen ist ja nur wirklich Paintchamp.
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee. Die einzige Sache, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es Probleme gibt, ist, dass man nichts an Tonnen dran kleben darf.
Mach doch einfach eine Kamera, die Müllmänner erkennt. Das wollte ich schon machen. Aber nicht die Müllmänner erkennt, sondern die Mülltonne erkennt.
Weil, das ist nämlich das nichts, was man auch machen könnte. Ich stelle die Mülltonne immer auf den gleichen Platz vorm Haus.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir den Platz auf dem Gehweg so ein bisschen markiere, mit einem kleinen Punkt, den keiner außer mir kapiert,
dann könnte ich eine Bilderkennung laufen lassen bei der Kamera, ob sich quasi in diesem Bildausschnitt von der Kamera, ob sich die Tonne nicht mehr dort steht.
Und wenn die Tonne nicht mehr dort steht, dann war die Müllabfutter. Das wäre auch noch ein Punkt, das wäre auch noch was.
Hackxy, nein, Hackyy, wahrscheinlich ist es Hacky, nicht Hackyyx, es ist Hacky. Er schreibt, er findet die Idee huge. Ja, wenigstens einer.
Ich habe mir jetzt eine Katzenmatte unter die Matratze gebaut, die das Haus enthält. Das ist eine richtige, was denn für eine?
Das suche ich auch schon eine Weile nach einer Lösung. Ich habe mir überlegt, also ich bin auch schon auf so eine Idee gekommen.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich nicht unter einem Pfosten vom Bett eine Katzenmatte habe.
Und wenn der Gewichtssensor belastet ist länger als, sagen wir, eine Viertelstunde, dann, also keine Ahnung, es ist nach 22 Uhr.
Und der Gewichtssensor ist länger belastet als eine Viertelstunde, dann schalte ich alles aus, was ich nicht ausgeschaltet habe, weil dann bin ich im Bett.
Was hast du für eine Matte drunter? Ist das hier ein Memestream? Nee, ich meine das ernst. Ich gucke, ich gucke keinen Film.
Also doch, ich gucke, ich gucke auf dem Tablet, aber dann bin ich ja im Bett. Dann kann der ruhig alles andere ausmachen.
Ja, Hacky, welche, welche Matte hast du denn unten drunter liegen? Weil die Idee finde ich gut.
Was, oh, oh, das ist natürlich auch gut. Was, eigentlich haben die Mülltonnen ein Chip, damit die Müllabfuhr abgerechnet kann, da nur x-frei abholen pro Jahr sind und die anderen bezahlen muss, wenn du es schaffst, den zu finden. Ist das eben ein RFID?
Weil ich habe so einen RFID-Reader, der nicht für diese normale Customer-RFID-Dinger sind, sondern für so RFIDs, die sie im Klamottenladen haben. Die hat ein bisschen mehr Reichweite.
Ich glaube, der passt nicht in den Griff von der Mülltonne rein. Den Griff von der Mülltonne müsste ich meinen eigenen Rüttelsensor mit dem ESP32 dran machen vielleicht.
Also, ich würde den Rüttelsensor mit Heißkleber an die Mülltonne machen.
Moment, wo waren wir denn hier gerade mit den Sensoren? Alter, was ist mit der Musik los? Das will ich nicht ausflippen hier.
Meine Mülltonne sieht so aus. So eine 0815 Mülltonne. So was hier. Und wo willst du da einen Sensor richtig anbringen?
Weil guck mal, wie klein der Griff ist. Da kann man doch keinen Sensor rein machen.
Die können doch einfach mal ausgetauscht werden. Ja, das wäre RIP, da wäre mein Sensor weg.
Vielleicht ist es über Bilderkennung mit der Kamera doch besser, wenn es gelehrt wurde.
Unter den Rand? Ich meine, das ist klein, das Ding. Seht ihr? Also es ist wirklich klein. Abmaße. Moment, Abmaße. Abmaße sind, das steht auch bei Amazon immer. Hier.
10 mal 7 mal 5. Also das ist ziemlich klein. Guck mal den Ding von Thronax an.
Was die Umwelt schon... Ja, das ist aber nichts für mich. Das ist doch eher was, was die Stadt da... Ah, guck mal.
Da ist sowas drinne, okay. Und mit was kann man das auslesen?
Das ist doch bestimmt so ein Custom Ding, was man nicht einfach so auslesen kann.
Ich könnte mal bei uns in die Mülltonne reingucken, ob da irgendwie sowas dranhängt.
Hab ich übrigens gesagt, RFC, ich meine NFC. RFC ist was anderes.
Ich finde, das ist, muss man mal gucken, ob man das irgendwie...
Mülltonne Transponder... äh, Müll... Auslesen. RFID-Chips.
Genau, ich meinte RFID, habe RFC gesagt und ich meinte gleichzeitig NFC. Ich bin... Abkürzung gerade, da hab ich drei Flüschen eingeschmissen.
Das sind RFID-Chips. Ja, da muss ich doch morgen mal in meine Mülltonne gucken, ob die sowas haben.
Exzellenter Chat. Hat sich schon wieder gelohnt heute, ja.
LED-Mülltonnen-Abholungsanzeige. Oh, guck mal. Ich bin nicht der erste, auf so eine Idee gekommen ist.
LED-Mülltonnen-Abholungsanzeige. Exquisite. Ach, Erinnerungsanzeige. Ja, das ist...
Was ist das?
Nee, das ist ja grausam. Dafür hab ich mein Tablet mit Dashboard... Dafür hab ich mein Tablet an der Wand hängen, mit dem Dashboard drauf.
Porgas UI, ja.
Ein Macher-Kit. Ja, das ist aber gut, Chat. Das ist gut zu wissen. Das werd ich mal kontrollieren, ob meine Mülltonne sowas hat.
Und dann werd ich mal versuchen, ob ich den Kram mit irgendeinem RFID-Laser... Ich hab zwei RFID-Laser, ich hab so einen NFC-Laser und ich hab so einen normalen RFID-Laser auf der Frequenz, was so zum Beispiel irgendwelche Klamottenläden machen.
Gucken, ob ich dort irgendwas detekten kann.
Ich könnte auch einen Abstandssensor nehmen, ja. Choose my name, das hab ich mir auch schon überlegt. Ich hab ja so Dinge, also hab ich schon...
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich nicht an das Kellerfenster einen Ultraschall-Sensor mache.
Und nein, das ist kein Memes-Typ, ich mein sowas ernst. Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich mir einen Ultraschall-Sensor an das Kellerfenster mache.
Und nachdem ich ja die Mülltonne quasi immer vor das Kellerfenster stelle, dann könnt ich mit dem Ultraschall-Sensor den Abstand erkennen, wie weit die Mülltonne vom Kellerfenster weg ist.
Ja, ja, also viel Big-Brain-Taktik heute wieder. Muss ich mir mal alles in Ruhe überlegen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eines der Sachen, die ich mal ausprobieren werde in nächster Zeit.
Und auf den ersten Blick scheinen halt diese Rüttelsensor-Geschichte am besten zu funktionieren.
Es ist direkt da dran, die Batterie hält relativ lang.
Allerdings, ich hab keinen Bock, dass die Mülltonne aus... Guck mal, man sieht ja, wie klein das ist.
Dass die Mülltonne austauscht und man Rüttelsensor weg ist oder dass die den abmachen und den Müll schmeißen oder so.
Kannst du mal eine Room-Tour von deinem Zuhause machen für YouTube?
Ich bin schon die ganze Zeit noch überlegen, ob ich mal irgendwie so eine Smart-Home-Tour machen könnte.
Aber ich bin mir noch nicht drauf gekommen, wie ich das möglichst sinnvoll machen kann, ohne da irgendwie aus Versehen Sachen zu leaken, die ich vielleicht nicht will.
Äh, ja, das mit der Katzenmatte hab ich übersehen, tatsächlich.
Was? Pentatech? Was? Was? Pentatech? Das könnte auch ein Gaming-Stuhlhersteller sein. Alarm, Drittmatte, Schwarz.
Excellent.
Was? Strahlung? Welche Strah... Okay.
Das sind Sachen, die kann man rational nicht erklären. Die sind halt... Das gibt halt...
Gott, ähm, wow.
Was ist das?
Okay, das hast du an das Bett gelegt und das erkennt, wenn du dich drauflegst.
Okay, versteh ich.
Muss man die regelmäßig aufpumpen oder reicht das? Ja, also... Oder, oder, oder ist das eher so eine Geschichte mit, wenn hier zwei, so quasi ein bisschen wie bei den billigen Touchscreens, wenn hier zwei Kontakte geschlossen werden, dann löst es aus oder so?
So, und ich möchte ja nicht, ich möchte ja nicht den Alarm auslösen, sondern ich möchte einen Signal bekommen. Das muss ich dann wahrscheinlich an irgendeinen Controller hängen.
Ja, das kann ich einfach als Input, das kann ich einfach als Schalter an irgendeinem ESP32 hängen. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee, das gefällt mir.
Besser als mit irgendeinem Gewichtssensor, das ist eine richtig gute Idee, das speichere ich mir auch mal.
Da kann ich das nämlich besser, besser machen jetzt.
95 dB, ja das Ding mache ich da bestimmt nicht dran, ich will ja nicht, dass mir das Ohr wegfliegt, wenn ich ins Bett gehe.
Wenn der Chat das machen könnte, der Chat kann das zum Glück nicht machen, weil der Chat nicht bei mir unter Wasser und das Bett liegen kann.
Das erste, was der Chat machen würde, ist heimlich den ESP abstöpseln und das Alarmanlagen-Ding anschließen.
Kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen.
So, also wunderbar, hätten wir das auch geklärt? Siehste, es ist immer gut, das ist immer gut, also du glaubst wir können das nicht.
Ja, gut, bei euch weiß man ja nie, ihr seid ja eh schon immer direkt in.
Sobald ich meine Local Host IP leake, seid ihr ja schon drinnen. Die alten Hacker-Mans im Chat.
Also 192.168.5.1 und sowas schon öfters mal geleakt und dann war hier gleich direkt.
127.00
Ich glaube, es ist sogar 1.000.000, oder?
00. Ich glaube, es ist sogar 127.8, oder? Was ist Local Host?
127.0.16
Ach, keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt kommen wir mal zu weiteren sinnvollen Geschichten.
Nee, nee, 001 ist nur ein Teil davon. 001 ist die erste, aber du kannst, Chat, jetzt gibt es wieder was zu lernen.
Weil, das muss ich euch nicht zeigen, das macht nicht mal. Du kannst genauso gut 127.0.0.2 machen.
Gut, ob das jetzt unter Windows geht, bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Guckt, Leute. Guckt mal, wenn das sogar unter Windows geht, da könnt ihr mir glauben, das funktioniert erst recht.
Sorix, vier Monate, Dankeschön.
Huge Subscription. Also, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie weit das geht.
Also, bis dahin geht es. Ich weiß nicht, wie es hiermit aussieht. Hier geht es auch noch.
Hier geht es auch noch. Okay, und hier wird es wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr gehen.
Okay, also das ist es, slash 8.
Gehe ich mal von aus. Ich gehe mal von aus, dass das 127.0.0.0 slash 8 ist.
Würde ich jetzt einfach mal so raten, was man da aus verwenden kann.
Weil, ich kann hier, können wir mal ausprobieren, 12.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist ziemlich sicher, slash 8.
Derrandaleur abonniert Twitch Prime. Huge Subscription, Dankeschön.
Hör mich auf zu dedossen.
Ja, gibt es ja echt Leute, die, du kannst mir sowas verwirren.
Schräge 8. Ja gut, es gibt ja auch Leute, die sagen C-Lattenzaun anstatt C-Sharp.
Mal gucken, ob man nach Google, Google Lattenzaun.
C-Lattenzaun.
Ach so, das ist so eine, so eine, wir machen uns lustig, Wikipedia-Eintrag.
Guckt mal, ich bin das erste, was man, eine der ersten Sachen von mir.
Ich installiere nun auf meinem Jubant, Jubantu.
Erstmal Java und C-Lattenzaun.
Damit man was von der Amazon-RP crepen kann, alles klar, so machen wir das.
C-Lattenzaun.
So, okay, also ich muss gerade mal kurz in meiner Einkaufsliste abhaken.
Toaster, na Toaster.
Haben wir nicht gemacht, aber so, Sensor haben wir.
Ja, gut, ob man was an die Mülltonne kleben kann, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, genau, und eine Sache, wo ich mal schauen wollte, was es so gibt, habe ich nämlich als nächstes draufstehen.
Meine Heizung spackt nämlich auch ein bisschen rum.
Und, ähm, ihr wisst ja, dass ich hauptsächlich C-Wave,
IoT-Geräte habe, wenn es um Wireless-Sachen geht.
Der Rest ist WLAN.
Äh, okay, es klingt, es klingt widersprüchlich, ja.
Aber, äh, C-Wave habe ich.
Aber die Sachen, die wirklich wireless laufen, ja, irgendwelche, ähm,
ich habe zum Beispiel im Fischteich hinten einen Sensor,
einen, äh, DS-2020?
Nee, äh, Temperatursensor DS.
Hier, den da.
Habe ich hinten im Fischteich einen Hängen.
Also so ein wasserdichter Temperatursensor.
Und der hängt an einem C-Wave-Gerät dran.
Das liegt halt daran, die Dinge halten halt richtig lange, was Batterie angeht.
So, und, äh, die Tür- und Fenstersensoren sind auch C-Wave.
Also sprich, alles was wirklich wireless mit Batterie läuft, ist bei mir C-Wave.
Und der Rest ist halt über WLAN.
Also sprich, die ganzen ESP32s, die Raspberry Pis, äh, die, die, äh,
die Steckdosen-Leisten hier, das ist WLAN.
Aber die sind ja auch nicht, äh, mit Batterie irgendwo.
So, und da wollte ich mal gucken, ob es ordentliche C-Wave-Thermostate gibt.
Ich hab mal vor Jahren eins gekauft, und das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Äh, das ist eine gute Frage.
Wanox, für alles.
Es gibt, es gibt fast nichts, was du nicht in C-Sharp machen kannst.
Eine Sache, wenn man unbedingt was finden will, würde ich sagen, du kannst in C-Sharp keinen Bootloader programmieren oder sowas.
Aber du kannst nahezu alles in C-Sharp machen.
So, ähm, ja, und dann wollte ich mal gucken, was da für Thermostate gibt, weil ich hab mir vor ein paar Jahren mal eins gekauft.
Mal gucken, ob es das hier gibt irgendwo.
Äh, nein.
Das war so mit Plus- und Minus-Buttons drauf.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie das da, aber das ist es nicht, weil ich nicht so einen Kringel dazwischen.
Das sieht gut aus.
Nee, oder? Nee, nee, das ist kein Z-Wave.
Zumindest hat mir das überhaupt nicht gefallen, und ich bin jetzt halt am Überlegen, ob sich das überhaupt lohnt.
Wieso spricht eine Heizung eigentlich nicht einfach deckt?
Ja, dann könnte ich das mit, ja, könnte ich auch machen, aber letztendlich, also könnte ich machen, das wäre gar kein Problem.
Ich könnte das auch über die Fritzbox machen, weil in Home Assistant kannst du ja mehr oder weniger jegliches Smart Home, habe ich jetzt mir noch gar nicht angeguckt, aber geht bestimmt auch, nahezu jegliche, äh, Sache integrieren.
Da kannst du auch diese Fritzbox-Geschichte integrieren.
Okay, Home Assistant Integrations Fritzbox.
Nee, das ist nur der Device Tracker. Ach guck hier, also die haben auch Integration Fritzbox. Ja, könnte ich auch machen, könnte ich auch machen.
Was hat die eigentlich bei denen so geritten, das über Deck zu machen? Wahrscheinlich weil es schon eh eingebaut ist in der Fritzbox und weil Strom sparen ist oder so.
Sag mal, schick mal, schick mal, äh, Chillfleak, die, die, äh, Zigbee, Zigbee Thermostate. Schadet ja nix, wenn ich auch ein zweites Zeug hab.
Weil Sie-Wave hab ich nix gefunden.
Wow!
Es ist schon... nicht ohne, ja. 5 Stück, also sprich, 190 durch 5, 40 Euro, naja gut, das kostet, das kostet zwar ein bisschen, aber es kostet ja auch ein bisschen, ja.
Es ist schon net ohne, ja.
Fünf Stück, also sprich 190 durch 540 Euro, naja gut, das kostet dieses komische Fritz-Ding
ja auch, ja.
Ja, weil die anderen, die Seawave-Dinger, ich meine, ich denke halt immer zuerst mal
dran, ok, holen wir halt was, was zu der Technik passt, die wir haben und ich hab halt relativ
viele Seawave-Dinger, allerdings, das ist alles Müll, das ist übrigens gar kein Seawave,
die Dinger sind mega kacke, wenn man sich die Bewertung durchliest, hier sieht das Produktfoto
schon aus wie mit meinem Klo fotografiert, oder, man guckt euch das mal an, wer hat denn
das Foto davon gemacht, was ist das, wer macht solche Fotos und denkt ernsthaft, der kann
was verkaufen, Paintschamp, mag sein, dass das Produkt ganz gut ist, aber das Foto sieht
echt aus wie 1995, MQTT, SIGB2 MQTT, die wollte ich mir installieren, es gibt zwei Sachen,
einmal das und es gibt noch irgendeinen anderen Gateway, die zwei wollte ich mir installieren,
falls ich wirklich mal SIGB Sachen verwende, was spätestens sollte ich mir so ein paar
Aquara-Sensoren holen, der Fall sein wird, so, und der Rest ist halt auch irgendwie, ja,
starkwürdig, so, und auch viel zu teuer, tja, ne, aber die finde ich tatsächlich nicht
übel hier, ist das China, und wie lange halten die, ja die Sache ist, ist das nur mit denen
ihre App, ist das nur mit denen ihre App bedienbar, weil, man muss ja sagen, SIGB im Gegensatz
zu Z-Wave ist nicht automatisch kompatibel mit dem anderen Zeug, also SIGB macht sehr
viel proprietären Kram, dass es vielleicht gar nicht funktioniert, so, guck mal mal,
das ist China, 100%, warte mal, Kiumi, was, Thermostat, wo ist der Hersteller, ich, das
ist bestimmt, das ist bestimmt China, was ist das für ein Hersteller, Yamion, das klingt
fast schon ein bisschen Japanisch, oder, ich habe gar kein SIGB bisher, ich würde mal gucken,
wahrscheinlich hole ich mir dann so einen, ich glaube so einen war das, ja, wahrscheinlich
hole ich mir dann so einen, Moment, ich habe so einen schon, aber ich habe den Einser,
nicht den Zweier, ich habe sowas schon, ich habe mir das vor zwei oder drei Jahren hatte
ich mir schon so einen geholt, aber nie verwendet, kennt sich hier eigentlich jemand mit der
Erstellung einer Docker-Container aus, also ich bin jetzt nicht, ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen, ich bin der Ultra-Profi, aber frag mal, so, was ist das für ein Hersteller, Yamion,
oh, China, China, SIGBI über Antenne vom Raspberry, wie man kann SIGBI mit dem Raspberry
noch ein paar Jahre ohne Adapter machen, wirklich, ist ja alles, aber, wie lange halten die denn,
das ist eher italienisch anstatt französisch, ich meine, ich finde die optisch wirklich
ganz cool gemacht, so teuer sind sie nicht, man könnte natürlich mal gucken, was der
ganze Spaß bei Aliexpress kostet, wie, ernsthaft, wie, das gibt es nicht bei Aliexpress, das
ist ein chinesischer Hersteller, warum gibt es das nicht bei Aliexpress, es gibt, ja,
der Sorschen, den meinte ich doch, den meinte ich doch, dass ich mir den wahrscheinlich
hol, what the fuck, warum gibt es das nicht bei Aliexpress, ist das doch kein China-Ding,
was ist das, ah, dass man weicher sitzt beim Fahrradfahren, ok, ähm, was sich alles
gibt, Kiyomi, was ist das für ein Hersteller, ach, Moment, wir müssen nicht nach Kiyomi
suchen, sondern nach Yamion, ich finde davon noch nicht mal den Hersteller, also, das erweckt
jetzt für mich nicht sonderlich Vertrauenserwecken, ehrlich gesagt, ja, Hersteller Yamion, Yamion,
soviel man nach dem, das findet man auch kaum, was ist das, ey, jetzt, das interessiert mich
jetzt echt, was für ein Hersteller ist das, gut, wir müssen jetzt nicht im Stream gucken,
aber, verdächtig, verdächtig, verdächtig, wenn man dazu nichts findet, sehr verdächtig
immer, ok, wir suchen einfach nach ZigBee Thermostat auf Aliexpress, aha, aha, aaaah,
das ist ein Tuya, es ist ein Tuya, den kann man sogar flashen, das ist wahrscheinlich
sogar ein ESP 2866 drin, erstmal Custom Firmware, erstmal Custom Firmware flashen, wobei, nee,
ZigBee wird kein ESP 2866 sein, das ergibt keinen, ergibt keinen Sinn, da ist es doch,
guck mal, Aliexpress, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, kannst du mal Aliexpress Link teilen,
ja, by the way, bevor ihr immer ewig lange Aliexpress Links kopiert, man kann einfach
den vorderen Teil kopieren, ist gut, wow, da muss man hier erstmal das, oh, das ist aber
fail, normalerweise kannst du was anderes auswählen und das ist deutlich günstiger,
egal, guck mal hier, da gibt's, da gibt's noch viel, viel mehr davon, da gibt's noch
viel mehr solcher Dinger und da mach ich mir auch keine Gedanken, dass sie nach Hause telefonieren,
weil die können nicht nach Hause telefonieren, die haben ja keinen WLAN, brand name Zitawel,
what, die Chinesen, ich hab manchmal das Gefühl, die gehen in ein englisches Wörterbuch, suchen
sich zwei Wörter raus und setzen die zusammen und machen das zum Produktname, total viel
dieser China Produkt Dinger heißen so komisch und es sollte mal Pepega und Poggers im Wörterbuch
stehen, da gibt's bestimmt dann auch demnächst in China ein Pepega Pog oder sowas, weil die
ihre Produkte haben, ich fühl random Würfeln, erstmal schöne Plastikschelle, hält bestimmt
richtig gut und wer bezahlt es, wenn die Wohnung unter Wasser ist, wobei hier sieht die Schelle
eigentlich, vielleicht ist das eine Plastikschelle, vielleicht ist das eine Plastikschelle im
Metall Look, wobei, ne, die können ja gar nicht unter Wasser setzen, das ist ja Blödsinn,
was ich erzähle, ne, ne, ihr habt ja Recht, Chet, Chet ist ja gut, ist ja gut, ist ja
gut, Chet, ich hab's jetzt verstanden, jetzt kommen erst mal 60 Dinger im Chat, dass da
nichts unter Wasser setzen kann, ja ihr habt ja Recht, da ist ja der Stift drin, der rein
rausgedrückt wird, da kann ja gar nichts unter Wasser sein, so anscheinend, anscheinend sind
die aber Mangelware, diese Dinger, die noch ganz, noch ganz gut, wir gucken jetzt einfach
mal bei Banggood, Zigbee, Thermostat, ok, die haben nix, Zigbee, Thermostat, die machen
schon gar kein Auto für Vollständigung, ok, also gib nur AliExpress, aber ich muss sagen,
von diesen ganzen Dingern sehen die noch, sehen die wirklich noch am besten aus, ja,
gut gesagt, aber da werd ich mich mal schlau machen, klingt nichts verkehrt, hast du dann
quasi ein Zigbee Stick im Raspberry Pi Steck, ja, wenn ich die, wenn ich so, wenn ich Zigbee
machen sollte, dann, ich würd ja immer noch lieber Z-Wave verwenden, weil ich hab schon
ein Z-Wave Netzwerk, welche Tablets hast du, ohje, da hast mich jetzt was gefragt, das
wird jetzt ne ganz schön lange Aufzählung, ne, nimm lieber den hier, äh, der geht aber
nur, wenn man, achso, nee, nee, mein Home Assistant läuft nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi,
das muss schon USB sein, so, das ist also hier, Frage, welche Tablets hast du, ich versuchte
es beim Schnelldurchlauf zu antworten, ich hab nen Nvidia Shield Tablet, was, äh, Monka
Smoke Akku hat, aber noch funktioniert, ich hab ne neues Nvidia Shield Tablet, was kein
Abfackel Akku hat, ich hab nen Tecranote 7, ich hab irgendein Lenovo Tablet, irgendein
Asus, also ich zähl erst mal nur die Android-Dinger auf, äh, ein Android, äh, nen, nen, Lenovo
Android, nen, Asus, Asus Android, zwei Fire HDs, nen Fire 7, ich glaube, das waren die
Android Tablets, genau, und dann noch nen iPad, nen iPhone 6 und nen iPhone Xe, Xs,
so, jetzt weiß es, ich hab bestimmt das eine oder andere vergessen, aber, so, so, es sind
so grob 10, 12 Tablets mal, schrägstrich, äh, inklusiv, mit inklusive Smart, achso,
und noch nen iPhone SE, hab ich ganz vergessen, ähm, ja, also so ungefähr 3 zu 1, was Android
zu iOS-Geräten angeht, du hast eine Docker-Frage oben drin, ok, da gucken wir da auch nochmal
schnell, Dockstore, Vom, also, Chat will mir nicht noch einer sagen, dass da gar nicht
die Heizung auslaufen kann, übrigens, zum Thema Heizung, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
ich schon diesen Stream mal erwähnt habe, wie gut ich meine Heizungüberwachung finde
und wie gut das funktioniert, weil, gerade, dass man hier erkennt, wie sehr die Pumpe
am schaffen ist, finde ich immer ganz interessant, da weiß man nämlich auch, dass das mit der
Heizung alles gut funktioniert, nur, was du nebenbei angemerkt, gell, also, cheatfim
Leute, was war, was war die Docker-Frage, äh, hier, ich will eine App in einen Docker-Container
packen, hab ich bereits gemacht, so, jetzt hat diese App allerdings ein relativ umfangreiches
Config verzeichnet, ich möchte effektiv gerne das verzeichnet als Volume mounten, ja, das
ist schonmal eine gute Idee, Problem, ich hab da ja einen leeren Ordner beim Boot vom
Container, kann man eigentlich bisum mounten, dass nur ein Teil im Container ersetzt, was
nur im Container ersetzt werden, die auf dem Host-Computer vorhanden sind und den Rest
aus dem Original, äh, äh, nee, mein Homesys kann ich gerade nicht zeigen, da sieht man,
äh, Geräte, Namen, Standort und so Dinger, äh, äh, äh, okay, nur, das, ich muss jetzt
mal, äh, Youngs9Lux, hol dir ein iPad, wenn du nichts da dran irgendwie jetzt super customisen
automatisieren willst, hol dir ein iPad, gerade im Tablet-Bereich ist, ist iOS besser, Smartphones
kann man sich wirklich streiten, aber ich hab nur wirklich alle möglichen Geräte ausprobiert
und meine, meiner Meinung ist, muss man sagen, gibt bestimmt welche, nein, nein, magst auf
gar keinen Fall, aber im Tablet-Bereich halte ich, äh, einfach zum benutzen, iPads für
deutlich besser, Smartphones kann man sich darüber streiten, äh, wo Android-Tablets
natürlich viel besser sind, ist, wenn man was automatisch machen will, das kannst du
mit, äh, also automatisch machen kannst du mit iOS vergessen, so, also, äh, so genau
hab ich's noch nicht, hab ich's noch nicht kapiert, also, wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
ist das Problem, wenn du das Config-Verzeichnis mountest, dann überschreib die Anwendung
beim ersten Start Dateien von dir, oder wie, also, ich mein, du könntest die Dateien auch
erst hin kopieren, du könntest die Dateien an einen anderen Ort kopieren, und dann, nachdem
die Anwendung gestartet ist, ist es irgendwie wieder hin, oder so, keine Ahnung, also, die,
so, ohne, also, Cheatfile, ich hab's noch nicht so hundertprozentig kapiert, aber eine Sache,
die mir so spontan einfallen würde, wenn's gar nicht anders geht, machst du einfach,
ähm, erst süngst du dir einfach die Dateien im Container woanders hin und lässt die Anwendung
halt von woanders, äh, einlesen, was, nee, andersrum, wenn ich, okay, Moment, da muss
ich mal runtergehen, wenn ich ein leeres Volume mounte, sind dann ja alle Configs weg, und
ich will eigentlich gar nicht, dass der User es selbstständig initialisieren muss, achso,
ah, also, du willst quasi den Container quasi so, so, beim Start mit einer Custom-Config
füttern, allerdings nicht alle 20 Stück, sondern nur eine, du willst quasi 19 Config defaults
lassen und eine Config beispielsweise beim Start überschreiben, ja, dann schreib doch
in dein Init einfach, cp rein, dann schreib doch in dein Init einfach rein, ähm, beim
Starten kopierst du die Datei in ein eigenes Verzeichnis, intern im Container, da wo die
anderen auch hin liegen.
Weil die Anwendung wird ja nix in der Config-Datei rumschreiben, irgendwelche Environment-Dinger
kannst du auch machen, ja, sofern die Anwendung Environment-Sachen liest.
Also, mit Dateien wäre das einfachste, einfach in das Startup-Script reinschreiben, ähm,
kopiere von dem, dem Verzeichnis, was gemountet wird, kopiere in das Verzeichnis, wo die Anwendung
ihre restlichen Default-Dateien drin liegen hat, und dann startet erst die Anwendung.
So, also, können wir mal weiter gucken, ähm, so, jetzt haben wir die Thermostat-Geschichte
abgehakt.
Also, das Ding finde ich echt cool, ne, das gefällt mir optisch ganz gut, achja, irgendjemand
hat doch gerade geschrieben, das ist supported, wo, wo gibt es die Liste, wo gibt es die
Liste mit, was, ähm, was war das MQTT to ZigBee, genau, ähm, supported, supported devices
oder so hier, ne, Thermostat, achja, sieht man irgendwo, wann die, wann das hinzugefügt
wurde, Citawell, Alter, so ein Kackname, das ist so ein, das ist so ein typischer China-Produktname,
Citawell, oder, no, Cytawell oder so, wie Cytawell, was, äh, eben hat das doch noch
gehabt, hier ist der GitHub-Issue, okay, Moment, kurz, schnell gucken, wann wurde das hinzugefügt,
okay, das ist ein ziemlich neues Produkt, China-Cita-Produkt, der Hersteller heißt
auch noch so, Alibaba, null, das ist, äh, das ist die, die Aliexpress, die Aliexpress
für, ähm, für, äh, Business-Kunden, okay, 100 Pieces brauche ich nicht, 100 Pieces
ist mir ein bisschen zu, zu viel, ehrlich gesagt, also, also 100, ich, ich brauche,
ich brauche keine 100, ich, ich habe keine 100 Heizkörper, kaufen wir 100 Stück für
den Chat, ich glaube, der Chat braucht auch keine 100 Thermostate, Balve, ups, okay, jetzt
sind wir nochmal bei Aliexpress, mal Banggood nochmal, das kucke ich, das kucke ich mir,
das kucke ich mir nach dem Stream mal an, was da für, was da für Dinge gibt, weil das
ist auf jeden Fall günstiger und wahrscheinlich auch besser, als wenn ich mir irgendein komisches
Sea-Wave-Ding für 50 Euro bei Amazon kaufe, äh, Home Assistant oder IO Broker, äh, ich
kanns, IO Broker nicht viel sagen, ich habe IO Broker nie ausprobiert, was mich bei IO
Broker, oder was, Open Hub, ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht, gar nicht sicher, da hat mir das
Web-Interface nicht gefallen, ich glaube, es war bei Open Hub, Open Hub hat irgendwie
vier Web-Interfaces, was ich mega verwirrend fand und außerdem ist Open Hub Java gewesen,
das war eh schon mal, ich so mein es dadurch, ja, IO Broker hat mir glaube ich auch das
Web-Interface nicht so direkt zugesagt und die Sache ist halt die, ähm, was ich halt
bei Home Assistant, was ich bei Home Assistant echt gut finde ist, erstens, dass die einen
saumigsten schnellen Release-Zyklus haben, dass auch Sachen schnell wieder gehen, wenn
sie mal kaputt gehen, äh, und das Web-Interface von Home Assistant ist halt richtig gut, das,
das können auch Kacknoobs bedienen, da kann man nichts sagen, ja, das, das, das kriegt
wirklich jeder bedient, was es gibt in IO Broker, das von, von Home Assistant, das kann
man mir nicht vorstellen, dass in der IO Broker das Home Assistant Web-Interface drin ist,
so, so sieht das, ja, also da sieht IO Broker, das IO Broker Web-Interface sieht halt schon
auch ein bisschen, äh, naja, nicht so angenehm aus, bei Home Assistant, das kann ich mir
gar nicht vorstellen, also Lovelace heißt das ja das, ach, guck mal da, what, die nehmen
IO Broker und haben das Home Assistant UI drauf gemacht, das funktioniert gescheit,
das funktioniert gescheit, na, ich weiß ja nicht, kann man das gar nicht vorstellen,
dass das ohne Probleme funktioniert, die Frage ist wieso, weil das ein richtig gutes Web-Interface
ist, interessant, hätte ich es nicht gedacht, dass es sowas gibt, ja, und kann man auch,
ja, aber du kannst keine Custom Cards und sonst was gescheit installieren, das ist ja
gerade das Gute da dran, na, du kannst ja bei Home Assistant hast du noch ein, äh, ein
eigenes Repo für Custom Cards und kannst da rumwursten, weil die Standard Cards sind
nicht so geil, echt, gibts das, ok, mit ein bisschen mehr manuellem Zeug, ja, aber die
Frage ist halt, war sowas immer, wie lange gibt es diese Adapter, wie lange wird das
gepflegt, ist es nicht vielleicht eine Einbahnstraße, weil das ja nicht zu diesem Projekt dazugehört,
ich denke mir dann, also ich, ich kann es jetzt schlecht begründen, aber so mein Bauchgefühl
würde mir jetzt eher sagen, dann nehme ich lieber gleich Home Assistant, auf der anderen
Seite weiß ich halt auch nicht, was IO Broker beispielsweise für einen Vorteil gegenüber
Home Assistant hat, also, mal von der Programmiersprache abgesehen, ist glaube ich IO Broker in C++,
was es für mich schon mal sehr unsympathisch macht, IO Broker, ich glaube IO Broker war
C++, oder nicht, oder doch, äh, wo ist das Source Code, Java Skript ist das, wo ist denn
das Source Code hier, bin ich jetzt bescheuert, Lib wird es ja schlecht, kann es ja schlecht
sein, wo ist das Source Code, IO Broker, was rechts an der Seite, what, ach hier, ok,
ok, ja, aber das ist es nicht, das ist nicht das Source Code davon, das ist viel zu wenig,
das muss irgendwo anders, irgendwo anders muss es das geben, ja, aber es ist Java Skript,
sieht man, ok, na dann hält es sich in Grenzen, dann ist, ja dann würde ich nicht sagen,
dass das eine besser ist als das andere, was die, also ich würde, würde Sachen da in
Paar heißen, sowohl in Java Skript basteln, solange es nicht C++ sein muss, ich hatte
irgendwie, ich hatte irgendwie im Hinterkopf IO Broker als C++, oder vielleicht ist es
doch was ganz anderes gewesen, das sind so 500.000 Zeilen Files, ok, IO Broker hat Blocky,
nee sowas brauch ich nicht, man kann ja auch, man kann ja auch bei Home Assistant, bei
Home Assistant kann man ja auch mit Node-RED dran rumdoktoren und dann so droppen, also
was ich, was ich an Home Assistant wirklich praktisch finde, dass man seine Automations,
entweder du hast ja eine Home Assistant, hast du drei Varianten deine Automations zu machen,
die Noob Variante im Webinterface, oder so, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube sogar auf
hier, so du kannst die Noob Variante im Webinterface machen, zusammenklicken, du kannst die Node-RED
Variante machen, es gefällt mir aber nicht, dann kann man hier seine Automations zusammenklicken,
sieht dann so aus, nach dem Motto hier, was weiß ich, Motion Detector hat ausgelöst,
das und das macht man, kann man machen, dann kann man sie in Jaml selbst machen, oder das,
was mir am besten gefällt, man kann sie in Python selbst programmieren, seine Automations
für seinen Smart Home und mir fällt es einfach leichter, so Logik in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache
auszudrücken, als Blöcke zusammenklicken oder irgendwelche Jaml Files oder Automations
im Webinterface, ich schreibe da einfach hin, keine Ahnung, wenn Uhrzeit größer gleich
sowieso und Sonne schon untergegangen, dann mach Rollern zu, ja, Hex ist richtig gut,
das ist zum Nachinstallieren von Webmodulen, von Frontend Geschichten, ja, also, das ist
mir in der richtigen Programmiersprache lieber, aber das hier ist gut zu wissen, ich book
mal mir den ganzen Kram hier mal, das muss ich mir alles mal auf Stream angucken, wir
kaufen jetzt aber erstmal weiter ein, so, weiter gehts, Citabell, der Name ist so geil,
Citabell, so ein typischer China Produktname, so, also was brauchen wir dann sonst noch
schönes, USB-Sticks können wir nachher mal gucken, genau, ich brauch zwei Sachen, noch,
ihr wisst ja, ich bin ja ein Fan von ordentlichem hochwertigem Werkzeug, es muss jetzt nicht
die Schweizer Diamant bestückte Edelstahlproduktion sein, aber zum Beispiel hab ich meine Seitenschneider
und die Rohrzange und so hab ich das Ding hier zum Beispiel wirklich top, die sind gut
und von denen hab ich auch die Seitenschneider und mir ist aufgefallen, ich brauch noch
eine ordentliche Kombizange, da hab ich eigentlich das Werkzeug, was jeder als erstes hat, hab
ich nicht, zumindest keine gescheite und ich hab aber keine Ahnung, wie das heißt, ich
brauch so eine vielleicht, wer ist das einer von euch, so eine, die so um die Ecke geht,
wie nennt man sowas denn, Spitzzangen, sowas, sowas brauche ich, ach guck mal, das gibt
mit Grad und mit Schäpp, soll ich einfach beide nehmen, kann man nie genug haben, gescheiter,
exzellent, Präzisions, den hab ich, den Seitenschneider hab ich schon, gerade größer schief, stimmt,
warum will ich eigentlich eine, die um die Ecke geht, das ist doch eigentlich komplett
sinnlos oder, ich hab mir, also warum ich mir sowas holen wollte ist, wenn man zum Beispiel
kleine Teile an Gehäusen nehmen, rausziehen will und sowas, aber da kann man das doch
genau so gut mit einer Grad machen, anstatt mit einer Schäpp, oder, macht doch eigentlich
auch keinen Unterschied.
Was, Sebaros Frage, was für Zangen kannst du empfehlen, ja die Knippex Dinger sind super
und die Dinger heißen ja tatsächlich, offiziell heißen die Knippex, aber jeder sagt Knippex,
du brauchst dir Schwitze, aber Kombizange braucht kein Mensch, echt nicht, aber gerade,
also zum Beispiel, warte mal, wo hab ich die denn, ne Moment, jetzt hin, aber so gerade,
wenn du mal irgendwie was festhalten willst und zum, dass du transzihen kannst oder so,
dann hast du doch damit deutlich mehr Kraft als mit so einem Ding, oder nicht, das täuscht.
Die Wasserpumpenzange hab ich schon, gut mit der Wasserpumpenzange kann ich auch transzihen,
die Spitze, ihr bezweifelt doch nicht, dass die gut ist, ok, exellent, oh Moment, hab
ich die jetzt gerade doppelt in, sehr gut, so, die wird auf jeden Fall, also wollte ich
eh holen, dann hol ich erstmal nur die, ihr Chat, ich glaub euch, der Chat wird mich ja
niemals jubalen, so, ähm, dann schauen wir mal weiter, gut, hätten wir das abgehakt,
Zange, spitzt Zange und benutzt die Wasserpumpenzange für größere Sachen, exellent, ja und jetzt,
weil anscheinend hab ich ja ein paar Leute im Chat, die auch, äh, äh, entweder handwerklich
Sachen machen oder zumindest ordentliches Werkzeug mögen, was haltet ihr denn davon,
äh, Pack, was haltet ihr denn von diesen, von diesen Geschichten, weil aktuell hab ich,
ich hab im Flur so ne wackelische Konstruktion aus Plastik-Ikea-Schränken, wo mein ganzes
Werkzeug drin ist und das sagt insofern, was hast du eigentlich, eine gute Seite, die den
E-Container gut erklärt, ja, äh, das sagt insofern, dass die halt erstens übelst wackelig
sind und, ähm, das sind doch nicht mal Ikea-Schränke, das ist so was, das ist so was,
wie gesagt, ich hab jetzt mal Ikea-Schränke gesagt, das ist was richtig billiges, das
ist übelst wackelig und, äh, die Schubladen haben auch ne sehr unhandliche Größe, also
da passt schon einiges rein, aber nicht genug und die sind zu groß, dass man das ordentlich
machen kann, also das ist irgendwie, nicht so, nicht so das, was lieber eine L-Box, was
ist denn eine L-Box, so was, ach so Dinger, hier, Alibaba Link und keine Mindestmenge,
exzellent, zeig mal her, aha, sehr gut, los, mal gucken, was die dafür versandt wollen,
guck, die, die, was, Thor, Timo, was ist das, ach, das sind die, das kenn ich, das ist die,
ja, das sind, das sind die, wo die, wo die in ihren, in ihren Montage-Dingern hinten
drin, ob das so für daheim im Flur so sinnvoll ist, wobei, warum nicht, ich mein, wenn du
jetzt ein Auto einbauen kannst, dann kannst du dir das auch daheim in den Flur stellen,
aber das ist wahrscheinlich so ein Ding, was wieder teuer as fuck ist, oder? Geht eigentlich,
das ist schon ordentlich teuer, Ben, Boxes and Cases, eigentlich ganz nett, warum sind
das eigentlich alles so Plastikkisten, na gut, wahrscheinlich, weil es leicht ist, ne, das
ist der Abhörwagen, es sieht, es sieht echt ein bisschen aus wie der Abhörwagen, mal gucken,
was hier der versandt kostet, das muss ich mir mal aufstreamen angucken, das andere Zeug
in Ruhe, ist hier, weil irgendjemand im Chat gesagt hat, Abhörwagen, ne, früher, da haben
die Leute sich immer so ein bisschen gegenseitig Angst gemacht, wenn man Fernsehen geguckt
hat, ohne dass man GEZ Gebühren bezahlt hat, dann haben, dann haben die Leute, also die
haben halt keinen Plan gehabt, aber da haben Leute immer behauptet, hey, guck mal da, da
steht so ein grauer Wagen, das sind bestimmt quasi die Abhörwagen von der GEZ, die gucken,
ob jemand illegal Fernsehen schaut, und als ich klein war, habe ich das noch geglaubt,
da habe ich wirklich gedacht, die GEZ oder wer auch immer, fährt rum mit grauen Wagen
und guckt, wer illegal, aber das wurde wirklich so erzählt, also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
was, wo ich mir da, wo ich mich reingestellt habe, nein, das wurde wirklich so erzählt,
vielleicht kennen das, vielleicht haben sie euch das auch teilweise noch erzählt, was
totaler Schwachsinn ist, du kannst das gar nicht richtig feststellen, ob jemand irgendwo
Fernsehe empfängt, weil, damals ging es ja noch so, damals war das ja ganz normal über,
also entweder warst du in der Wohnung, es war Kabel, oder halt Satellit, oder halt ganz
normal über die Antenne, und das ist ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen wie bei GPS,
es gibt auch keinen GPS Sender in dem Sinn, und es gibt halt auch keinen Fernsehsender
in dem Fernsehgerät, sowohl GPS als auch ein Fernseher, der einfach nur da steht und
das Signal empfängt, der empfängt was, was eh schon da ist, also sprich, deswegen kann
man ja auch mit GPS nicht geortet werden, das einzige was geht ist, man kann GPS empfangen
und dann über den anderen Weg den Standort versenden, diese Sachen, die sie dann teilweise
in irgendwelchen Filmen erzählen, er wird über GPS geortet, ist kompletter Schwachsinn,
du kannst über GPS niemand orten, das funktioniert nicht, GPS ist quasi Read Only, wenn du so
willst, ich kann, wenn ich irgendwo auf der Welt bin, ich hab ein Gerät mit GPS, dann
kann mir dieses Gerät berechnen, wo auf der Welt ich bin, das geht, aber es kann niemand
anderes sagen, aha, der Max ist jetzt da, weil er GPS empfangen hat, Link zu PXE Container,
das hier hab ich, das da, du musst auch nichts machen, du musst einfach den Container starten,
wirklich, du musst nichts machen, Container starten und in deinem DHCP Server dort die
IP des Systems, wo der Container drauf läuft, die trägst du in deinem DHCP Server als Next
Server ein, das war's, mehr musst du nicht machen, das ist tatsächlich Bluetooth, das
ist irgendwas anderes, kein Zigbee, aber ich guck mal, die Dinger gibt es garantiert noch
überall anders auch zu kaufen, Creamy, derPlugAdder.com, die China Seiten werden immer besser, der PlugAdder,
das war mal so eine, das ist so eine uralte, das ist so eine uralte englische Comedy Sendung
mit MrBean gewesen, aber dann hat man sie anders geschrieben, derPlugAdder.com, guck
mal, AliExpress, da sind wir doch, wisst ihr, das verwirrt mich manchmal an AliExpress,
dass manchmal die Seite komplett anders ausschaut und dass manchmal Produkte auftauchen, die
man vorher nicht gesehen hat, das ist so Illuminati bei, wenn ich jetzt danach suche auf AliExpress,
wahrscheinlich finde ich es nicht, jetzt finde ich es nicht, jetzt findet man es einfach
immer wieder nicht, WTF, ah, dieser Artikel ist leider nicht mehr verfügbar, ok, exzellent,
so und das ist das was man eh schon gefunden hat, ok, was ist denn, das lohnt sich ja mal
überhaupt nicht, Versandmethode, ich brauche Versandmethode 2,50 Euro, ne, ne, ne, meist
verkaufte Modelle, machen wir das mal zu, gucken wir uns mal was nächstes an, ja, AliExpress,
deswegen kann ich es ja auch verstehen, dass viele Leute Bedenken haben bei AliExpress
zu kaufen, weil ich meine ernsthaft, AliExpress sieht auf den ersten Blick wie eine China
Scam Seite aus, also wenn du dort irgendwie einen Link auf die Suche bekommst bei AliExpress,
man sieht das, für sie ausgewählt, wie der verwendbare Mausepfalle, für mich ausgewählt,
alles klar, AliExpress und deswegen, AliExpress sieht halt auch für Leute, die es das erste
Mal sehen, das sieht aus wie eine Scam Seite, hat die WLAN bestimmt, die sagt dir dann
ein paar WLAN Bescheid, IoT, IoT Maus Trap, Moment, das gibt es wirklich, Smart Maus Trap,
Peter, oh es ist Peter recommended, ja wenn die Peter das empfiehlt, dann kann ja nix
schief gehen, Smart Maus Trap, so smart sieht die nicht aus, die sieht einfach aus wie eine
Plastikgehäuse mit einer Tür dran, was ist daran smart, hat die ne App oder so, das Ding
ist doch keine IoT, das ist ne Plastikgehäuse, was ist daran smart, also ist keine IoT, IoT
Maus Trap, aber es gibt eine IoT Enabled Maus Trap, alles klar, Kingwall schreibt, mein
Onkel hat sich letztens ein Carbon Rahmen für sein Rennrad gekauft bei AliExpress,
ja wundert mich nicht, auf der Arbeit hat sich irgendein Typ, frag mich nicht, ich kenn
mich mit Autosachen nicht aus, irgendwelche Verbindungsstecker oder so, das ist so einer,
der gerne ein bisschen rumtunt an seinem Auto, bei AliExpress gekauft und er meint da muss
man aufpassen, weil manche Sachen werden am Plastik, was halt, wenn du es von einem ordentlichen
Hersteller kaufst, aus Metall ist und sowas, ich glaube im Auto ist halt Sachen, die aus
dem Plastik sind, wenn sie aus Metall sein sollten, schlecht, ist die Hälfte nicht sofort
Schrott wenn man was bestellt, nö, ich hab bei AliExpress ganz wenig Schrott bekommen
bisher, also es war mal ein Kabel kaputt, es war mal eine Raspberry Pi Mini-USV kaputt,
aber das allermeiste vollkommen intakt und top, ich mein, wie gesagt, ich würd bei AliExpress
keinen Kühlschrank bestellen oder so, das nicht, und Sachen, die an 230 Volt rankommen,
würde ich mir auch doppelt überlegen.
Ja, auf CE-Zeichen kannst du dir eh nix geben, weil CE-Zeichen kann sich jeder selbst verleihen.
Ach Chat, ich hätte da nochmal ne Frage, bevor wir jetzt hier... vielleicht kennt sich
ja jemand von euch mit 3D-Druckgeschichten aus, und zwar, wenn man was aus dem 3D-Drucker
macht, dann sieht man ja so Streifen, also je nachdem, wie gut der 3D-Drucker ist, aber
man erkennt, dass die meisten 3D-Drucker, also das ist jetzt ganz extrem, aber die meisten
3D-Drucker, du erkennst halt auch, wenn es gut gemacht ist, die Schichten, gibt es irgendwie
die Möglichkeit, das ordentlich zu kletten, also ich hab jetzt beispielsweise ein YouTube-Video
gesehen, da haben sie das glaube ich nicht in Säure eingelegt, aber in irgendeine Säure-Ausdünstung
eingelegt, und dann ist das irgendwie verlaufen, und dann ging das, aber das ist nicht für
das Material von meinem 3D-Drucker, gibt es da irgendwas einfaches?
Aceton, ja, aber ich glaube, das geht mit meinem Zeug nicht, da muss ich glaube ich
mit anderem Material drucken, weil abschleifen ist ja nicht, oder was heißt abschleifen,
also polieren oder so, glatt Dingsen ist ja nicht so wirklich, ich muss sagen, diese
Gehäuse, die ich für meine ESP32 Sachen und sowas ausdrucke, das geht okay, die sehen
vollkommen in Ordnung aus, aber manchmal fände ich es cooler, wenn die noch ein bisschen
glänzender und klatter außen wären, schleifen geht meinste, mit abs kannst du, ich glaube
aber nicht, dass abs defaultmäßig ist, also ich hab den hier als Drucker, so und ich weiß
nicht, was da standardmäßig dabei ist, aber standardmäßig ist es wahrscheinlich PLA,
oder?
Da ist so eine fette Rolle mit weißem Zeug dabei, genau so, also ich hab das Zeug drucken
ich aktuell mit der default PLA Rolle, dann hab ich noch ein paar farbige, die waren auch
dabei, ich blick da eh nicht so genau durch, es gibt irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 15 verschiedene
Materialien oder so, mit denen du drucken kannst, und das einzige was ich kapiere ist,
dass man, es gibt so elastische Materialien, das sieht ein bisschen wie Gummi, das verstehe
ich, was PLA geht mit Chloroform, ich hab keine Ahnung, bisher war ich damit halt ganz
zufrieden für sie, die 0815 Microcontroller Gehäuse oder irgendwie sowas, ist das vollkommen
ausreichend alles, aber manchmal fände ich es echt cooler, wenn es ein bisschen glänzender
noch wäre, ein bisschen klatter und glänzender, keine Ahnung, es gibt auch so Carbongedöns,
da muss ich mich mal schlau machen, abschleifen und anmalen, anmalen ist eigentlich eine gute
Idee, einfach so eine Spraydose nehmen, so eine Spraydose nehmen und weiß Farb drüber
machen, ok also was, schau dir das Video an, zeig mal her, also mal auf die schnelle,
auf die schnelle jetzt mal, guck mal jetzt nicht, also 3D-Druck bearbeiten sehr effektiv,
ok erstmal wird da abgehobelt oder sowas, keine Ahnung, ja aber das ist ein riesen
Aufwand pro Druck, ich hab ja keinen Bock, 2 Stunden zu drucken und 4 Stunden zu basteln,
boah nee, das wird zu viel Aufwand, das ist mir zu viel Aufwand, das ist mir, ok ok das
sieht gut aus, das sieht gut aus, aber das wird zu viel Aufwand, da guck ich mir lieber
hier hübsches 3D-Druckergrill an, was kriegen wir hier, was kriegen wir hier gezeigt, exzellent,
alles klar, aha, D.Va, ist das Overwatch D.Va, könnte sein oder, ja eindeutig, nee aber
das dauert mir zu lang, guck mal, da druckst du 4 Stunden und dann bist du noch mal 4 Stunden
mit Schleifen und Malen beschäftigt, das ist mir für so kleine Gehäuse, dann lieber
nicht glänzend, egal, machen wir mal weiter, ich muss doch ein paar Sachen, paar Sachen
mal bei Amazon gucken, so was haben wir dann als nächstes, genau, ich brauch unbedingt
wieder USB-Sticks und diesmal will ich aber USB-3-Sticks, weil das letzte was ich hatte,
die sind diesen 20er-Pack USB-Sticks, die haben zwar auf der Arbeit ganz gut funktioniert,
wie gesagt ich hab ja letztens auf die Arbeit so ein Pack USB-Sticks mit, so Aliexpress
USB-Sticks mitgenommen und die sind auch alle verbraucht mittlerweile, einer ist komplett
kaputt gegangen, hat direkt den Geist aufgegeben, da haben wir den SSH-Key drauf kopiert, also
irgendwie fragt mich nicht, 3 Kilobyte und dann hab ich ihn bei mir beim Rechner reingemacht,
den Aliexpress USB-Stick wieder runter kopiert und beim nächsten Mal in den Rechner stecken
war er kaputt, also der hat zweieinhalbmal anstecken und auslesen überlebt, weil beim
letzten Mal haben wir nicht mehr beschrieben, dann war er kaputt, also Aliexpress USB-Sticks
ist so eine Sache und die waren lahm, irgendwie 3MB die Sekunde oder sowas, der allerletzte
Scheiß, so und jetzt ich brauche wieder ein paar USB-Sticks, weil ich habe außer diesen
einen 8G USB-Stick, ich habe nichts mehr, ich müsste irgendwo noch 2 32G haben, aber
ich hab am besten will keine Ahnung mehr wo die sind, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich
kauf mir mal ein paar ordentliche USB-Sticks, so fünf Stück, ihr wisst ich kauf nie Einzel,
ich kauf immer mindestens drei, bei so kleinen Scheiß, und zwanziger Pack muss es auch nicht
sein, also irgendwie dreier Pack, dreier Pack was halbwegs ordentlich ist, schau doch mal
bei Aliexpress, ne ne ne, das nicht, so das hier sind auch schon irgendwelche billige
Dinger 100 pro, die hatte ich, die hatte ich, zwanziger Pack davon hatte ich und die waren
so dermaßen scheiße, was, der Sebaro sagt Sahndisk, was, kurzer, oh das ist aber ganz
schön, aber das sind USB 2, ich brauch Max, Max FPS, USB 3, was die heißen jetzt, ultra,
ach die da, also den wollte, da hab ich mir schon ein paar mal überlegt ob ich den kaufen
soll, was mich davon abgeschreckt hat, die zu kaufen ist folgendes, hier schreiben total
viele Leute, erstens, dass die sau schnell überhitzen und dass die sau schnell kaputt
gehen, hab ich hier in den Bewertungen gelesen, very short lived, not so good, unstable, defective,
best fall so, kann man das nicht auch einfach auf deutsch einstellen, also jetzt so wirklich
richtig gut sind die Bewertungen nicht und es gibt keine Probleme damit ok, also ich
will die ja auch nicht verwenden als, sagen wir mal, Raspberry Pi Betriebssystem Hut-Petition
oder so, weißt du zufällig welche Smart-Steckdosen Max verwendet, das muss dir der Sebaro nicht
sagen, das kann ich dir auch sagen, wir haben sogar ein Ref-Link dazu, also ich hab zwei
verschiedene Smart-Steckdosen, eigentlich hab ich ein paar mehr, weil ich unten Zeug
ausprobiert hab, aber die wichtigsten, ich hab einmal ein paar Z-Wave Steckdosen und
ich hab ein paar Steckdosen-Leisten, die ich selbst geflasht hab, also die Steckdosen-Leisten
die ich selbst geflasht hab waren die hier, die gibt es so nicht mehr, aber es gibt vergleichbare
Sachen bei Amazon, man muss nur gucken, dass man welche findet, die man flaschen kann,
das ist gar nicht so einfach, also es muss was mit ESP8266 sein, dass man die selbst
flaschen kann, das Motor drauf machen und dann hast du am Ende so ein Web-Interface,
wo du die schalten kannst, natürlich kannst du das auch über deine Heim-Automatisierung
schalten, entweder über HTTP oder MQTT, also das funktioniert jetzt, kein Ding, so, das
ist das erste, das ist die, davon hab ich drei, bilde mir ein, ich hab vier, drei oder vier
und die, die ich letztens gekauft hab und im Stream versucht hab zu flaschen, die kannst
du vergessen, die geht nicht, das war die hier, die geht nicht, die sieht exakt genauso aus
wie die andere, aber hat eine andere CPU drin, lässt sich nicht flaschen, so und dann hab
ich noch, ich glaub bei Notebooks, billiger hab ich die mal gezeigt, oder SeaWave Smart
hier die da, und das verwende ich für mein SeaWave Mesh Netzwerk, um es stabil im Haus
zu verteilen, die Dinger, das sind SeaWave Steckdosen und bei SeaWave ist es so, dass
Geräte, die man an der Steckdose betreibt, dass die quasi das SeaWave Mesh Netzwerk weiter
verbreiten und stabiler machen, deswegen geht das SeaWave Netzwerk auch bei mir bis zum
Fischteich hinter und ich kann von dort Temperatur übertragen, ich hab's ja so, ich hab im Fischteich
hinten einen Temperatursensor und der sendet zweimal am Tag die Temperatur vom Fischteich
und wenn es unter 5 Grad geht, so nach dem, oder ich glaub 7 oder, ich weiß nicht genau
was ich eingestellt hab mehr, zumindest schickt es dann eine Warnung und zeigt dem Webinterface
eine Warnung an, dass man jetzt mal den Fischteich abdecken muss, weil es sonst gefriert und
das Fleisch kaputt geht.
Ich muss dir zugeben, hat einen gewissen Anteil, einen gewissen Big Brain Anteil, funktioniert
auch ziemlich gut, so und deswegen hab ich ein paar SeaWave Steckdosen im Haus verteilt.
Warum deckt sich der Fischteich nicht selber ab?
Stimmt, das ist eigentlich die logische Frage, was man da, was für Fische sind da drin?
Oh, zwei verschiedene Sorten, Goldorfen sind da drin und irgendwas anderes, keine Ahnung,
ich kenn mich mit Fischen nicht aus.
Wie viele Gigahertz haben die Fische, also chat, manche Fragen sind schon, da fällt
mir nichts drauf ein, ja, also ich erzähl ja schon im Stream viel Blödsinn, aber auf
manche Fragen, ich weiß auch, dass sie nicht ernst kommen, da fällt mir einfach nichts
blödes ein, was ich sagen könnte.
Zum Beispiel, wie viele Gigahertz die Fische haben, keine Ahnung, die haben RGB die Fische,
wenn ihr euch das mal genau anguckt.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie viel FPS und wie viel Herz, die haben aber durch RGB auf jeden
Fall mehr.
Guckt euch das mal an, RGB Fisch, RTX, dort ist, guckt euch das mal an, also da ist auf
jeden Fall RTX on, so gucken wir mal, USB Sticks, also die hier, wow, what the fuck,
also chat, ich vertraue euch da jetzt, ja, wie gesagt, ich will die Dinger ja gar nicht
verwenden als Root-Partition für meinen Raspberry Pi, also wenn ihr sagt, ihr habt die teilweise
hunderte so übertrieben gesagt im Einsatz, ab und zu mal verwenden und sie gehen immer,
die sind ja billig, da bestelle ich mir jetzt einfach mal fünf Stück von, so langsam wird's,
habe ich euch schon erzählt, dass man mit Amazon Prime kostenlos subscriben kann auf
Twitch.
Ich finde, das ist jetzt der passende Moment, wo ich das mal erwähnen sollte, ganz schön
was zusammengekommen hier, na gut, aber alles Zeug, was ich mir holen muss, Nanotoxical,
Twitch Prime, Subscription, exquisite, Any Primers, genau, ich hätte das abpassen müssen,
als die ganzen großen Channels auf Mixer und auf YouTube und so sind, mein außer Dr Disrespect
sind die alle wieder da, dass wir Dr Disrespect hier noch mal sehen, glaube ich net, da haben
total viele andere Channels in den Titel geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, Shroudsubs welcome und
so ein Blödsinn, habe ich leider verpasst, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass mir so viele Shroudsubs beim Amazon Shopping gerade zugucken.
Hast du dir eigentlich mittlerweile ein AirTags 3090 gegönnt, sieht das so aus, als habe
ich mir so eine gegönnt, oh guck mal hier, es sind wieder welche lieferbar, das ist wahrscheinlich
wie dieser Kack-Shop, das ist wahrscheinlich wie dieser Kack-Shop, alter, die sind echt
nicht mehr bei Drohoster, also das ist nicht mehr PC King, der das macht, sondern andere
Hersteller, nee, sehe ich nicht ein, sehe ich nicht ein, mache ich nicht, mache ich
nicht, kaufe ich mir erst, wenn es die zu normalen Preisen wieder regulär gibt.
Hast du wegen Dr Disrespect gelesen gehabt mit dem Bum, nee habe ich nicht, was denn,
was Twitch wollte angeblich einfach Geld sparen, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
wer hat denn das gesagt, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, ich meine, die haben mit
dem den Vertrag vorher abgeschlossen und die müssen, je nachdem wie das war, müssen
die auch garantiert dem trotzdem was bezahlen noch, das glaube ich nicht, oder es wären
auf einem der beiden Seiten die beratenden Rechtsvertreter echt unfähig gewesen.
Wie findest du den neuen Chromecast 4 mit Google TV, habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt,
habe ich auch keine Verwendung für, warte mal Leute, ich muss gerade übelst husten.
So, alles klar, so jetzt haben wir auch USB-Sticks gekauft, ich sehe ja heute kaum mehr vorwärts,
hat man das husten gehört, obwohl du gemutet warst, ja es kann sein, wenn man laut hustet,
dann geht der Mute-Knopf nicht so gut, warte mal, ich probiere es noch mal aus, ja das
hört man, wenn ich, also der Mute-Knopf ist nicht so hundertprozentig aus, wie man denkt.
Wie hat sich das jetzt eigentlich gerade angehört, ziemlich kaputt oder, als wärst du in der
U-Boot, ja das ist, also der Mute-Knopf, der ist älter, und das ist jetzt kein WIT-Chat,
mein, als ernst, der Mute-Knopf ist älter als viele Leute von euch im Chat, das ist
nämlich ein, das ist noch der Mute-Knopf von einem Microsoft Sidewinder Headset, und das
kam raus 99 oder, ne hier, 2001, gibt es hier einen Test dazu, der Mute-Knopf ist älter
als einige Leute im Chat, weil die Leute sind 19, die hier geboren sind, älter als
du, siehste, damals hatte man auch noch so ultra High-Rest-Fotos in so Testartikeln und
sowas, und wie gesagt, das hätte das Zeug ja schon lange weg, aber diesen Mute-Knopf
habe ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen behalten, und ja, da ist das MMX300 dran, ich finde
auch sonst keine Mute-Knöpfe, und es kann durchaus sein, dass der Test sogar noch älter
ist, guck mal, das sogar von 2000.
Okay, die Marketing-Chance-Gelaber-Zeug war damals schon genauso wie heute, ja, huge,
huge Computer, das ist die Spiel-Age-of-Vampires, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass das Grill
aus dem Bild heute 20 Jahre älter ist, so alt ist das Zeug schon, changing the face
of gaming, also ihr seht, die haben damals schon genau den gleichen Blödsinn marketingmäßig
geschrieben wie heute, ja, und also wie gesagt, das ist von 2000 und dementsprechend älter
als einige von euch im Chat, guck mal, da ist die Ad-Werbung von 2000, toll, tja, so
mal habe ich diesen Mute-Knopf schon, geht heute gut, naja, also wie gesagt, ihr habt
gehört, der Mute-Knopf macht nicht mehr ganz Mute, und manchmal knistert es auch ein bisschen,
wenn das Kabel falsch liegt, aber ich kenne nichts anderes, ich hätte viel lieber so
einen richtig fetten Mute-Knopf, auf dem ich draufhauen kann, das Ruhe ist, fällt mir
aber sonst nichts ein.
Kennt ihr mal einen Mute-Knopf, einfach einen Knopf, wo man sowas hier, sowas in der
Rechnung im Prinzip, einfach so einen Mute-Button, für Klinkelstecker, baut ihr doch selbst
was, nee, da muss es doch irgendetwas Fertiges geben, große Enter-Taste und was genau soll
man damit machen, kann draufhauen, man kann sich die Teile gut mit dem 3D-Drucker drucken,
ich hätte halt gerne irgendetwas Fertiges, wo ich einfach drauf gehe, ich meine, gerade
auch Audio-Studio mäßig, müsste man doch eigentlich für so einen Mute-Button, irgendeine
Verwendung, aber ich habe auch bei Tormann schon geguckt und nichts gefunden, so also,
ich muss bei USB-Sticks abhangen, USB-Sticks haben wir auch gekauft, diese komische Webcam,
ja, keine Ahnung, ich werde mir für die Arbeit die billigste Webcam hier irgendwie holen,
so keine Ahnung, sowas da, alles viel zu teuer, irgendetwas, so, irgendjemand hat auch hier
so eine billige Webcam gepostet und sowas hier, genau, irgend so ein 15-Euro-Ding, perfekt,
nee, ich mache das nicht mit der Kinect-Kamera, weißt du, wie groß und fett die Kinect-Kamera
ist, die kann ich nicht, die kann ich wieder unter, noch auf dem Monitor, noch vor dem Monitor machen,
die Kinect-Kam ist, das Ding ist übelst fett, guckt euch mal an, da fällt mein Monitor nach hinten um,
das Kinect 2, ja, nee, das ist das, was bei der Wind und was bei der Xbox One dabei war,
chat, clogs, das ist die beste Webcam, ach du Scheiße, was ist das denn, ach du große Kacke,
also das ist doch eine Art Trappe, oder, das ist doch eine Art Trappe, das ist gar keine echte
Kamera, das ist eine Art Trappe, das wird keine echte Kamera sein, oder, das kann doch nicht sein,
nein, what the fuck, oh, oh, das USB-Kabel, das sieht aber äußerst widerstandsfähig aus,
ok, genau, aus den 50 Megapixel und hier stehen 0,5, nee, 5 Megapixel, die haben einfach das
Komma mal vertauscht, außerdem sagen Megapixel auch nur die Hälfte aus, das kommt doch an,
wie viel Licht da rein fällt, also, alter, was, was ein Schrott, das ist ja Negerschrott,
ey, vor allem, dass sie dann hier vorne noch was dran gemacht haben, was wie ein Objektiv aussieht,
welcome to my shop, follow and buy now, oh, oh, oh, da werden wir kommandiert jetzt, wir müssen jetzt
kaufen, Leute, follow and buy now, ich kann nicht sagen später, jetzt, jetzt muss das bestellt werden,
zu meinem Freunde, die China-Texte sind immer beste, zu meinem Freunde, danke sehr viel für
Ihre Interesse in unsere Einzelteile und wünschen Ihnen eine angenehme Kauf, wenn Sie irgendwelche
Fragen über unsere Einzelteile, bitte zögern Sie nicht, uns zu kontaktieren und wir sind immer
hier mit Sie, willkommen in der Masse kaufen, die mehr Sie kaufen, die mehr bietet Sie haben,
die mehr Sie kaufen, die schneller die Logistik Aktualität, alles klar, ich meine, man kann
ungefähr verstehen, was er sagen möchte, umso mehr man kauft, umso schneller geht der Versand,
aber das ist schon Next Level Skills, durch die Weg, wenn Sie unseren Speicher mögen,
mögen Sie bitte unseren Speicher, Ihre Lieblingsspeichert, Sie können erhalten unsere
neue Ankunft und Rabattenformation, okay, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, das hier habe ich noch
kapiert, was er damit sagen wollte, aber das verstehe ich wirklich nicht,
die mehr Monate Sie haben, die mehr gesagt, ja das kann man noch zu sehr lesen,
danke schön, 15 Monate, das ist ja schon, danke schön, Poggers, so, warum ist die Farbe
eigentlich anders, warum ist die Hintergrundfarbe pro Satz hier anders, 100% Marke, neue und hohe
Qualität, natürlich, also Leute, ihr müsst schon zugeben, also wenn das Ding hier nach was aussieht,
dann sieht es eindeutig nach 100% Marke, neue und hohe Qualität aus, findet ihr, also besonders die
hohe Qualität, sticht einem direkt ins Auge bei diesem Bild, bestechend hohe Qualität,
konzipiert für Laptop und Desktop, High Definition, wahre Farbe, Bilder, richtig wahre Farbe, 360 Grad
Drehfunktion, wo hat das Ding bitte eine 360 Grad Drehfunktion, ich meine, außer er geht davon aus,
das zählt, wenn man mit der Hand die Kamera rumdreht, aber wenn es danach geht, hat sogar
mein Kühlschrank eine 360 Grad Drehfunktion, das ist eh, na gut, kompatibel mit USB 2,
CC 2000, Ziel, Net Meeting, what, wann habt ihr zuletzt das Wort Net Meeting gehört, Net Meeting,
ICQ, das ist ja mal top aktuell, Net Meeting ICQ MSN Messenger, das ist ja Wahnsinn, Spezifikation,
maximal dynamische Pixel, statische, ach jetzt sind es so, what, Moment, was, 6000 x 800, ja,
ist klar, 6000 x 800, 8 Zentimeter Unendlichkeit, 8 Zentimeter Unendlichkeit, das ist ja gut,
Signal Rauschverhältnis, mehr als 48 dB, sollte man es nicht eigentlich andersherum angeben,
unterhalb von, na gut, ach hier sind es jetzt wieder 50 MPC, alter was ein Schrott, neue hohe
Qualität, guckt euch mal das USB Kabel an, was ein Schrott, der Aufkleber ist gerade drauf,
das Topmodell von 1999, was ein Schrott, also ja man kann bei Aliexpress gut und günstig Sachen
einkaufen, aber manchmal gibt es doch einfach nur Schrott, aber das sieht man vorher oftmals und
das ist halt einfach Schrott, das Sebaro, der Sebaro kennt sich wieder aus hier, oh man,
so, was gibt es da, genau, also eine Sache wollte ich mir noch bei Amazon holen und zwar,
ich wollte mir jetzt endlich mal ein ordentliches Gehäuse für mein Raspberry Pi 4 holen und zwar
ich habe auf YouTube dieses Gehäuse gesehen, da wollte ich mal gucken, das Video kam erst
gestern raus, ich glaube von dem, das da, das da, das Case hat nämlich einen sehr
nice Eindruck gemacht, so mal gucken, ob es das gibt, Amazon, das neue Case gibt es noch
gar nicht, das ist nämlich das alte, da habe ich mir auch schon mal überlegt, ob ich es mir
kaufen soll, habe ich mir gedacht, ne, aber das neue fand ich jetzt ganz gut, weil sie jetzt noch
einen Slot für eine M2 SSD reingemacht haben, dann warte ich noch bis es bei Amazon das neue
Gehäuse gibt, ich habe es ja nicht eilig, ich meine ich benutze mein Raspberry Pi 4 ab und zu
mal für irgendwelche Sachen, die wir hier im Stream machen, aber ob der jetzt nebendran steht
ohne Gehäuse oder in einem ordentlichen Gehäuse ist eigentlich auch vollkommen egal, ich kaufe mir
dann das 2er, das gibt es ja schon irgendwo anders zu kaufen, M2 Case, das dauert bestimmt
wieder 5 Monate bis es bei uns in Deutschland ankommt, Argon 1, heißt das jetzt Argon 2?
Argon 2, Case, was Stage, hä, was hat der da gemacht?
Case, okay gibt es in Deutschland noch nicht, Amazon hat oben die deutsche Flagge und ist zum
Teil englisch, das liegt nicht an Amazon, da kann Amazon überhaupt nichts für, das liegt an meinen
Browser Settings, mein Windows steht auf Englisch und meine Browser Settings steht auf Englisch,
da versucht Amazon das beste was es kann, dass es zu meinen Browser Settings passt.
Bis jetzt bei einem Zigbee Thermostat finde ich gewonnen, wie gesagt eigentlich wollte ich
einen Siebelheft Thermostat, aber diese, nein, nein, nein, nicht das, sorry, das ist komische Kacke,
die erscheinen mir hier wirklich ganz sympathisch, aber ich will mir die nicht in Deutschland kaufen,
ich muss nachher mal gucken, ob es das nicht in China zu kaufen gibt, ein bisschen günstiger
und nicht 100 Stück, aber ansonsten gibt es natürlich noch zig andere Möglichkeiten,
ne, und ich kann dir halt auch gar nichts empfehlen, weil ich ja nicht ausprobiert habe,
aber das werden wir im Stream ausprobieren, das können wir uns gleich schon mal aufschreiben,
Zigbee, Sugbee, das ist was von der, ja, Sugbee, genau, das probieren wir aus,
das im Home Assistant einzurichten, ob das dann auch die Heizung ordentlich steuert. Habt ihr eine
Idee, was man machen kann, wenn die Heizung gar nicht mehr richtig an und aus geht, also
ich hab hier die, also bei mir hier oben im Arbeitszimmer, ich nenne es jetzt einfach
im Arbeitszimmer, ist die Heizung immer an und der Stift am Thermostat bewegt sich,
also der Stift hinter dem Thermostat funktioniert, kann ich rein und raus machen, kein Problem,
ich habe auch schon mal ein bisschen leicht drauf geklopft auf den Stift und alles,
das funktioniert, alles wunderbar, der Stift geht rein und raus, das Thermostat geht auch und,
das vermute ich mal, aber die Heizung ist immer aus, also die Heizung, nein trotzdem,
die Heizung geht nicht mehr aus, so rum. Meinung zu ABAP, das ist irgendwas von SAP,
habe ich noch nie was mitgemacht, aber, also wenn ich die Kombination lese,
proprietäre Programmiersprache der Firma SAP, da weiß ich gleich, damit will ich nichts zu tun haben.
Nee, nee, nee, habe ich keine Erfahrung, damit will ich auch nicht, ich meine,
guckt euch das mal an, was ist der, und dann, was, was, was, hä, nee, nee, geh mal fort,
das ist ja abartig, ja, man kann es lesen, aber, ist das so eine Mischung aus SQL und,
und objektorientiertes SQL oder, was ist das, das sieht aus wie jemand, der SQL genommen hat
und daraus eine möchtegern objektorientiere Programmiersprache gebastelt hat, so sieht das
aus, also nach was total beschissenem, bist du mit Shopping durch oder fehlt noch was,
also Raspberry Pi Case, ja gut Batterien für die Türsensoren, aber das ist jetzt nichts
wichtiges, Wasserwaage habe ich auch gekauft, die, die Packs haben wir uns auch angeguckt,
ich brauche eine wasserdichtes Verlängerungskabel, das ist jetzt aber auch nichts, wo man großartig
suchen muss, also, Dicht, Verlängerung, ja, irgendwas davon, was auch immer, das muss
ich jetzt nicht im Stream kaufen, ja, und dann suche ich nach einer Weile schon nach einem
kleinen Netzwerkschrank für, für Switche, aber da muss ich ja auch nicht gucken. Was,
du hast den selben Toaster gekauft, echt, den hier, den da, oder welchen, den da, exzellent,
kennst du Cobol leider, ja, ich kann aber kein Cobol, ich kenne aber, also ich kenne
Cobol und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich kein Cobol kann, weil ich Cobol gesehen hab
und hab mir gedacht, das willst du gar nicht können, ja, bin ich mal gespannt, wie der
so ist, wahrscheinlich werde ich den nachher bestellen, ich hab ja schon hier, wir haben
ja heute ein paar Sachen schon auf die Liste gesetzt, Weihnachten wird ein toller Stream,
ja, an Weihnachten muss ich Cobol programmieren, der Chat hat mich dazu überredet, dass wir
an Weihnachten, ich weiß auch nicht, ich weiß, warum an Weihnachten, sollte man an Weihnachten
nicht Sachen machen, die irgendwie toll sind, die einen freuen oder so und dann, und dann
Cobol, das sind irgendwie zwei Sachen, die nicht zusammenpassen, nee, der, der gefällt
mir nicht, Leko, der gefällt mir nicht, der sieht so, so grün gestreift aus und ich will
auch keinen mit Schrank, ach was denn, was laber ich denn, ich will keinen Schrank mit
Schrank, ich will keinen mit Tür und Glas, einfach 19 Zoll, äh Moment, ja doch, einfach
19 Zoll, wo man einen Switch reinhängen kann, ne Schublade rein machen kann oder einen Zwischenboden
rein machen kann, wo man dann Fritz Borgs Kabelmodal drauf stellen kann und an die Wand
hängt und nach Möglichkeit ohne Glas und nach Möglichkeit ohne Tür, weil das kommt
bei mir ja alles in diesen kleinen Serverraum rein und ihr seht, wie klein das ist und hier
oben an die Wand kommt das dann und das sollte so wenig Platz wie möglich wegnehmen und hat
auch keinen Sinn, dass ich deine Tür aufmachen muss. Erlang ist auch witzig, Erlang ist die
Frage, ob sie irgendwelche Klammern nicht verwendet haben, ich meine, in Erlang gibt
es ja, Erlang sieht ja aus wie so ein Fisch, wie so ein Fisch Emote von früher, so, das
ist ein gültiges Erlang Programm hier wahrscheinlich. Schau mal bei Turmalink 19 Zoll Racks, ja
die haben meistens doch nur so relativ große Audio-Dinger oder? Da hatte ich nämlich mal
geguckt, bevor ich mir das hier gekauft habe. Max braucht das hier, das ist gar nicht so
übel, das ist ungefähr so ein bisschen in der Größe wie das, was ich gerade habe. Ja,
sowas ist hier nicht verkehrt, weil an der Seite darf es zu sein für die Netzwerkgeschichte
und oben darf auch ein Deckel drauf sein und unten darf es auch zu sein, aber ich habe
hier schon was, was ziemlich Raw-Gestelle ist. Aber wie gesagt, ich will halt was kleines
für Netzwerk, da kommt dann rein der 10G-Switch, ein oller billiger TP-Link-Switch, das Kabelmodem
und also die Fritzbox und der Mikrotik-Router, das kommt dann rein, fertig. Ja, da ist so
ein oller TP-Link, warum soll ich den wegschmeißen, der funktioniert und gibt noch ein paar Ports.
Der 10G-Switch hat ja nur 5 Kupfer-Ports. Ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich, wenn
ich einen Netzwerk-Schrank habe, ob ich mir da nicht einen 24-Port-Mikrotik-Switch noch
dazu kaufe, dass ich endlich mal genug Ports in meinem Server-Schrank habe, in meinem Serverraum
habe. Ach, das ist diese Ikea, das ist die Ikea-Geschichte, oder? Ja, das kenne ich,
das kenne ich. Ne, ne, das ist zu groß dafür. Ich brauche irgendwas, was man an die Wand
hängen kann, wie gesagt, da wird es ja an die Wand hängen, deswegen suche ich ja auch
so ein kleines Netzwerk, so ein kleiner Netzwerkschrank. Ich habe ja schon ein Werk, was auf der Erde
steht, das sind glaube ich irgendwie 16 HE, oder 18, oder 17, oder irgendwas in dem 15,
ich habe mir hier irgendwas in dem Dreh, das passt auch ganz gut, steht da auch gut, aber
der Raum ist relativ hoch und deswegen piezt sich das an, das auszulagern. Ja, und dann
kaufe ich mir wahrscheinlich noch irgendeinen TP-Link, ich fasse nicht TP-Link, anstatt
dem TP-Link kaufe ich mir wahrscheinlich echt noch für den nächsten Mal einen 24-Port-Mikro-Tic,
muss ich mal gucken, welchen irgendwie sowas günstiges hier. Guck mal, wie günstig die
Dinger sind, da kaufe ich mir so ein, das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, ich kaufe mir
so ein, ich weiß gar nicht wieviel Strom die brauchen, ich kaufe mir einfach so ein, ach
Moment, oder so ein, die haben wir noch mehr, also ich könnte mir so einen kaufen, dann habe
ich sogar noch 10G-Uplink-Ports, die ich an den anderen 10G-Switch machen kann, das ist
eigentlich ziemlich gut, dann geht es per 10G an den 10G-Switch, wo dann auch der Fileserver
und Gedöns dran hängt, und dann habe ich 24-Ports, das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht,
aber das ist neu, das kenne ich noch nicht, den kenne ich noch gar nicht, was kostet der,
kann man den überhaupt kaufen, ne, den kann man natürlich nicht kaufen, kann man den,
ist der neu, der ist ganz neu, weil ich gucke öfters, ich gucke öfters in den Mikrotik-Shop
rein und, seit wann gibt es den denn, der ist mir noch nie aufgefallen, wird da irgendwie
Release-Datum, genau, News, ja guck mal, haben die hochgeladen am 22. September, der ist
sehr neu, ja, ok, das ist ein CSS, da kann es nur Switch OS drauf machen, gibt es den
auch als CRS bei Mikrotik, nein, der andere Seite juckt mich das nicht, ob Switch OS ist
oder nicht, auf dem Ding mache ich eh nichts, zumal dort eine CPU drin ist, mit der du auch
nichts machen willst, ja, das ist eigentlich ein cooles Ding, das ist eigentlich ein richtig
cooles Produkt, wenn man sich überlegt, was die da wieder gemacht haben, man bekommt zwei
10G Ports, acht normale Ports und das ganze für 92 Euro, da kannst du dich wirklich nicht
beschweren, generell kann man sich bei Mikrotik nie beschweren, was den Preis angeht, welcher
Router war das nochmal, den man zusammen mit der Fritzbox benutzen kann, eh, jeden, Meinung
zu Unify-Gedöns, also Wireless finde ich super, ich habe einen Ubiquiti 10G-Switch, das ist
aber kein Unify-Switch, das ist ein, so einer, kein Unify-Switch, der ist auch ein bisschen,
bewegt sich in ein bisschen höheren Sphären, ja, was, 224, das ist übelst billig, ah Moment,
das ist ein anderer, das ist ein anderer, das ist ein anderer, vergiss, vergiss, vergiss,
vergiss, das ist ein anderer Switch, das ist, das ist ein anderer, bin ich jetzt gerade nicht
wie viele Ports, der was hat, das ist ein anderer, ok, ne, also den habe ich, den habe ich, weil
das damals eines der einzigen wirklich brauchbaren und halbwegs erschwinglichen Switches war,
mit ein paar 10G-Ports dran, der hat glaube 12, 12 SFP Plus 10G-Ports und 4 Kupfer 10G-Ports,
also das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt, ja, ja genau, und wie gesagt, WLAN-Wi-Fi mäßig
finde ich das Ubiquiti Unify Zeug echt gut, kameramäßig ist es glaube ich auch nicht
schlecht, da habe ich nur eine und die verwende ich nicht über Unify, sondern einfach so,
darauf zugreifen, da habe ich hier Flex G3, weil sie so schön klein ist, die kommt zum
3D Drucker, gegenüber von 3D Drucker und ja, ich glaube das ist auch ganz ok, ein Kollege
bei mir auf der Arbeit hat sein ganzes Haus, Unify Kameraden, das scheint wohl ganz gut
zu funktionieren, aber da kann ich nichts zu sagen, wie gesagt, Wi-Fi Dinger ist wirklich
gut, ich habe hier die Kombination bei mir aus AC Pro, UAP hieß das doch oder, genau,
ich habe die Kombination aus dem Access Point hier und damit ist, ich bin gerade, ich bin
übrigens am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht noch einen dritten hole, damit ich den Hof komplett
abgedeckt bekomme, also aktuell habe ich die zwei Access Points, einmal den hier unten,
Nano HD Access Point, irgendwie sowas da, so und das ist wirklich eine super Kombination,
der Unify Controller läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi, ja die UAP Pro sind End of Life, als ich
den gekauft habe, dann war es aber noch nicht End of Life, jetzt ist klar, ich habe zuerst
den UAP Pro geholt und dann ein bisschen später, ein Jahr später oder so den Nano HD und jetzt
würde ich mir auch den Nano HD wiederholen, ja und das kann ich empfehlen, das ist auch
wirklich gut und der Unify Controller tut auch seinen Dienst, also bei zwei, drei Access
Points muss man sagen, ist diese ganze Unify Controller Geschichte fast schon ein bisschen
Overkill, ich meine, wozu brauche ich eine extra Management Box, wenn ich zwei Access
Points habe, die könnte ich ohne Probleme auch von Hand einstellen, aber wenn man dann
drei hat und ich denke spätestens bei vier Access Points ist der Punkt erreicht, wo sich
es auch wirklich lohnt, zumal es sich die Frage gar nicht stellt, weil man kann das
ohne Unify eh nicht gescheit verwenden, man hätte sonst nur die Möglichkeit die Access
Points über WLAN, also über die App zu konfigurieren, das ist scheiße oder über SSH und das ist
unsupportet, also Müll, ich dachte Informatiker kaufen sich kein Smart Home, warum, gerade
Informatiker sollten sich Smart Home kaufen, weil die wissen wie man es richtig macht,
naja hoffe ich mal, die meisten wahrscheinlich auch nicht, das wichtigste beim Smart Home
ist eigentlich nichts Fertiges kaufen und keine bescheuerten China Cloud Produkte verwenden,
vor allem nichts Fertiges kaufen, wenn man nicht weiß was es macht, wenn man weiß was
es macht kann man ruhigwertige Sachen kaufen und integrieren und wenn man das ordentlich
macht gibt es da eigentlich auch keine größeren Gefahren denen man sich aussetzt, wenn man
sich irgendwas von der Stange kauft, was dann am besten noch mit Smart Lock an der Haustür
und Schiss und Gedöns, ey dann muss man sich nicht wundern, ja Alexa ist so eine Glaubensfrage
ein bisschen, ich persönlich bin da kein Fan von jeglichem Voice Assistant, also ich habe
weder Siri noch Alexa noch Cortana noch Hello Google oder Google, hey Google, okay Google
heißt es ja, okay, ohje Leute ich hoffe jetzt ist bei euch nicht zig tausend Sachen angesprungen
im Hintergrund, dann, ey du kannst es nicht aussprechen, du kannst es nicht aussprechen
ohne dass irgendwie was im Hintergrund angeht, naja ich habe es überall aus und gerade am
Rechner bin ich der Meinung es ist auch überflüssig, gerade am Rechner habe ich schneller getippt
als irgendwie einen Voice Assistant ich ein Kommando gesagt habe, einzige Sache wo ich
es sinnvoll finde ist wenn man Auto fährt und dort irgendwas eingeben möchte, aber ansonsten
habe ich keine Voice Assistant und habe auch noch nicht mit dem Gedanken großartig gespielt
bei mir daheim irgendwelche Cloud Voice Assistants hinzubasteln, sollte ich jemals, oder was
heißt jemals, jemals zu lang, sollte ich in nächster Zeit irgendwelche Voice Assistants
verwenden, dann werde ich mal probieren ob es irgendwelche Projekte gibt, dass man sowas
selbst laufen lassen kann, gibt es ja schon ein paar, die sind dann aber nicht so schön
integriert und wenn ich mal Sachen wie, ich sage die Namen jetzt nicht, aber wenn ich
mal Voice Assistants von den großen Hersteller verwenden sollte, dann weiß ich auch nicht
welchen, keine Ahnung, dann zumindest nicht mit Echo und sonst wie Gedöns permanent always
on in der Wohnung, ja Dom PC hast du natürlich vollkommen recht, könnte ich machen aber nachdem
ich jetzt schon angefangen habe, wo ich jetzt schon angefangen habe mit dem Unify Zeug,
da bleibe ich bei WLAN auch noch bei dem Unify Kram, weil jetzt gerade mit einem dritten
Access Point dabei, wird sich ja sogar noch wirklich lohnen, dass man jetzt das Unify
Zeug hat, da war es wieder, was war?
Echo, echt, das ist ein Trigger, Alter, da kannst du ja gar nichts mehr sagen, ohne nicht
dass irgendwo ein Voice Assistant anspringt, nee bei Unify, ich bleibe erstmal, ich bleibe
erstmal bei Unify Geschichten was WLAN angeht und bei Mikrotik was Router und Switches angeht,
wobei selbst da ist ja auch nicht eindeutig, ja so sieht es aus, wir haben heute tatsächlich
die Sache hingekommen, wenn ich mir das angucke, ich habe mehr oder weniger alles was ich haben
wollte drin, der Chat war mega Big Brain wieder, weil gerade die Sachen mit, dass ihr mich
auf die Idee gebracht habt, mit Bilderkennung beispielsweise bei der Mülltonne ist richtig
Big Brain oder auch diese Mülltonnen Tracking Geschichte, das ist schon Massive und auch
diese Zigbee Geschichte, das muss ich mir alles mal in Ruhe angucken, so wir haben jetzt
noch 5 Minuten Zeit, wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns jetzt noch das PS5 Tear Down Video
oder Tear Down, Tear Down, was ist es denn?
Das ist Tear Down oder, weil es weint ja nicht, es weint ja nicht, es wird ja auseinander
gerobbt, Tear Down, ok, dann gucken wir uns mal an, also was machen die da, ah yes, das
ist immer so diese Haftungsausschlüsse, Alter, do not try this at home, Wrist of Ox, Exposer
to Laser Radiation, Radiation, Strahlung, Strahlung, gut, Strahlung kann ja alles sein, Schock
und andere Verletzungen, wenn man die PS5 auseinander nimmt, dann verfällt die Garantie,
oh, nee, ich hab nicht, klar wegen dem Laufwerk, nee, ich hab, was mich verwirrt hat ist Radiation,
aber Radiation ist ja einfach nur Strahlung, ich hab jetzt irgendwie die radioaktiven Sachen
gesagt, hä, Laser, was soll da dran rad, aber die meinen damit einfach nur Laser, also
man kriegt Laser ins Auge und das kann schlecht sein, wenn ihr mal wirklich was sehen wollt,
was schlecht ist fürs Auge, dann guckt mal in so ein Dark Fiber Glasfaser Ding rein,
also wenn sie nicht mal Dark ist, dann ist das Auge, hat, hat ein Loch im Auge, ah,
okay, das ist ein riesen Ding, ey, oder er ist so klein, eins von beiden, wahrscheinlich
ist er so klein, der Chat ist im Weg, oh Mensch, mach den Chat aus, excellent, das ist wahrscheinlich
beides, die Konsole ist groß und er ist klein, also jetzt mal ernsthaft, ein trockeneres
Video hätte man nicht machen können, oder, also ich bin ja normalerweise kein Fan von
super excited amazing best console ever, never world never seen before gaming experience,
das muss ja auch nicht sein, aber das ist schon sehr trocken, oder, superspeed USB 10G,
Moment, 10G USB, 10G, 10G, 10G bedeutet, es ist nicht USB 4, es ist USB 3.2, GEN 1,
was ist es, USB 3.2 GEN, also es kann auf jeden Fall, es kann auf jeden Fall kein USB
4 sein, weil USB 4 muss mindestens, muss glaube mindestens 20G haben, nee, T1 Dark 3.1 war
das ursprünglich mal, aber das USB Forum benennt das ganze retroaktiv um, das USB 3,
also wenn ihr denkt, dass es USB 3.1 ist, dann ist das falsch, weil das USB Forum, die
namensgebung für USB zuständig ist, es hat gesagt, USB 3.1 gibt es nicht mehr, es gibt
jetzt USB 3.2 GEN 2x2 und sowas, also wahrscheinlich ist das USB 3.2 GEN 2 und nicht 2x2, irgendwie
mag ich japanisch, irgendwie mag ich das, vor allem, was ich richtig geil finde, wenn
die so, die reden nicht energisch, die reden so auf den Punkt zackig, ich mag japanisch,
und was ich auch cool finde, dass die an englische Wörter immer Os und so hinten dran hängen,
das ist dann kein Port, das ist dann ein Porto und sowas, USB Porto, Type A Porto, ja, Speedo,
so viel Porto, ja, ok, ja, also, damit hätte ich gerechnet, dass es ein HDMI Port, Stromanschluss
und Netzwerkstecker hat, das hätte ich mir vorher gedacht, ok, Lüfter, ok, kommen die
Videofilme rausgeblasen, das ist ja ein riesen Schraubendreher, was ist das für ein riesen
Ding, ist das Glas, ist das durchsichtig, das ist der offiziell zertifizierte Playstation
5 Öffner, das ist so geil, keine Musik und nichts, was, ok, man kann den Stand drehen,
alles klar, ok, man kann sie auch hinstellen, auch gut, also man kann sie hochkant stellen
oder hinlegen, ok, das ist ja schon mal was, das habe ich mir vorher aber auch schon gedacht,
dass ich ehrlich bin, aber das ist riesengroß, ne, wie so einfach geht das, ah ne, ah ne,
wenn der Fuß abgeht und ich glaube, er wollte damit gar nicht sagen, dass man sie auf die
Seite legen kann, sondern er legt sie jetzt auf die Seite und macht sie auf, aber ich
gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass man sie auf die Seite legen kann, weil warum nicht, das
Belüftungsgitter passt überhaupt nicht zum Rest, ne, dass es relevant wäre, ok, Staubfilter
ist gut, Staubfilter ist schon mal gut, ja, also Staubfilter sind immer gut, aha, ok,
man kann eine M2 reinschrauben, Moment, warum kann man da eine M2 reinschrauben, haben die
nicht erzählt, die PS5 kommt mit so einer ultra hyper speed, noch nie dagewesene, beste
SSD ever, gut vielleicht ist die zu klein, dann kann man noch eine M2 reinstecken, erstmal
den Garantieaufkleber weg, Moment, habe ich das richtig gesehen, man muss die PS5 aufmachen,
um die M2 rein zu bekommen, da sind doch die 0h15 Noobs daheim wieder komplett am verzweifeln,
die gehen dann zum, wie heißt dieser Laden bei den Amis, Geek Squad oder so und lassen
das machen, oder bei uns gehen die Leute in den Mediamarkt oder in Saturn und fragen,
könnt ihr eine M2 in meine PS5 machen, da sagt dann der Mediamarkt, was willst du,
der hat ja noch weniger Plan, GameStop, ne, GameStop nicht, GameStop macht sowas nicht,
die gehen dann zum Mediamarkt, das wird der Mediamarkt anbieten wahrscheinlich für 100,
genau, wollte ich gesagt, für 100 Euro oder so, ja Mediamarkt hat Garantien, SSDs, ok
erste mal dicke Noctua Lüfter, auch wenn es kein Noctua Lüfter ist, aber ich stelle
mir jetzt einfach mal vor, es ist ein Noctua Lüfter, so ein ordentliches Ding, ob es am
Ende wieder zusammenkriegt, optische Laufwerke in 2020,
Blu-ray juckt mich absolut nimmer, weiter, ok, Wi-Fi 6, Bluetooth 5.1, immerhin, das
Wi-Fi 6, das finde ich schon mal ziemlich gut, es ist nicht wirklich relevant jetzt
so, ah also, war Wi-Fi 6, hatten die da nicht dieses Feature mit automatischem Band raussuchen
und sowas, Wi-Fi 6 hatte noch ein paar richtig nice Features, neben einfach nur schneller,
als nächstes wird erstmal, als nächstes wird erstmal bei Aliexpress eingekauft, aber
man kann es ja vergessen, ich was denn, gibt es nicht, aber vielleicht könnte er uns ja
noch irgendwie, bisschen die Anschlüsse zeigen, dass man gleich weiß, wo man custom
Firmware flaschen kann, oder ich kann ja erstmal jailbreaken, ja, das wissen wir schon,
ja, was, Moment, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, ah hier, hier, was, das da, da scheint
mir jetzt ein bisschen wenig für 825 g so zwei so dinge vielleicht zusammen
ach die drei dinge ne was wollte ich gerade sagen also eins da haben die ganz schön
kleinen flash speicher ist die es ist der ssd controller größer als die grafik
hatte nicht das richtig die haben von intel gelernt
also indirekt intel hat ja mal eine weile ihre cpus nicht mehr verlötet und da kamen
die leute auf die idee das auseinander zu machen und flüssigmetall dazwischen zu schmieren
kann ich kann ich bestätigen funktioniert richtig gut habe ich bei mir nämlich auch
im rechner gemacht ich mein warum sie überhaupt flüssigmetall warum verlöten sie das zeug
nicht na gut die verlöten es nicht weil das nicht mal das dann nicht mehr abkriegst wenn
es verlöten würdest es wäre bescheuern dann kriegst du kriegst kannst du nicht mehr auseinander
machen weil die frage ist ob du es wenn du es auseinander machst dann musst du dann
neue neue flüssigmetall drauf machen
das ist nichts neues also ich weiß nicht warum die zwei jahre gebraucht haben wie man flüssig
mit ok wir nehmen das einfach mal zur kenntnis dass sie das als mega high end technologie
darstellen wollen dass da jetzt flüssigmetall dazwischen ist also ihr könnt euch bei amazon
für 15 euro eine tube flüssigmetall kaufen da ist dann so ein watte stäbchen mit ein
bisschen kohle drauf dran das könnt ihr nehmen und auf eure cpu schmieren also da ist keine
höhere big brain sache erforderlich
das zeug ich gehe auch stark davon aus dass du das zumindest mal neu auftragen musst wenn
du aufgemacht hast ja
ich habe fast ich war fast richtig muss man aber sagen
das ist ein netzteil hat aber dachte ich mir fast schon
ja gut da ist aber also das schon ein fettes teil aber so viel drin ist da nicht warum ist
das jetzt so groß
da ist doch da ist doch sau viel fläche einfach nur verschenkt oder
guck mal hier neben ist nix drin
wahrscheinlich weil es zu heiß wird sonst
naja klar aber guck mal hier neben hast du massig platz wo nix ist
das mainboard sieht auch übelst leer aus aber gut das ist jetzt schwer zu sagen aber
hat nicht der patrick sogar freund gemeint er hätte das 70 prozent kleiner hinbekommen
weiß ich jetzt nicht aber es sieht wirklich verdammt leer aus für so ein mainboard
das sieht das ist wirklich groß und dafür ist gar nicht mal so viel drin
als kollega
kollega was hat der dann damit zu tun
der ist halt überall dabei
ok jetzt wissen wir bescheid ja also ultra fettes ding von der größe her immer guck
mal das geht ihm vom bauch bis zum kopf
mag vielleicht jetzt auch nicht der größte aber das ist ein riesen ding
das ist massiv
und sony hat keinen ordentlichen schraubendreher
xbox ist doch auch so groß keine ahnung
das habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt die aktuelle die neue xbox interessiert mich sogar
noch weniger aber die aktuelle ps4 ist bei weitem nicht so ein fettes ding
der discord post
das ding ist wirklich schon groß holst du dir eine ps5 line ich hole mir keine der
beiden konsole zu release ich habe neben mir hier eine xbox xbox one stehen und eine ps4
beides hier beides ihr seht es jetzt nicht aber ich ich halte ich halte es mal vor beides
day one 2013 edition
und ich habe sie insgesamt fragt mich nicht fünf stunden angehabt oder so die unsinnigste
konsolen investition aller Zeiten für mich
ich habe wie gesagt beide konsolen zum release gekauft und beides komplett
was habe ich da jetzt gemacht grad
chat was habe ich gemacht was war das
ich habe ich habe es irgendwie editiert oder
was war das
du hast oben aus utf
ok ich habe keine ahnung was ich gemacht habe
ito paipo ja das wird das wird es nicht sein
wie dem auch sei
mehr kann ich denn was soll ich da mehr fällt mir da nicht ein
was ich da zu ps5 sagen soll also außer dass es ein riesen teil ist
und ich werde mir was ich habe auf feedback gedrückt echt
ich weiß ja nicht mal wo der feedback knopf überhaupt ist
ach da also click on the error
dieses ist mir noch nie aufgefallen dass es überhaupt existiert
ito paipo
alles klar leute wir sehen uns nächsten stream ich gehe jetzt auf muss ins bett mal wie wir
das schaffen
heute waren wir echt erfolgreich haben alles auf die reihe gekriegt was wir machen wollten
wann baust du deinen neuen pc mit der ryzen cpu naja wenn ryzen cpus rauskommen
und verfügbar sind vorher kann ich ja nicht aber dann so schnell wie es geht
weil ich kann es kaum ich halte es kaum noch aus hier ich brauche unbedingt neuen rechner
ist denn warum ist das hier denn warum ist das hier denn rot wenn es hier nicht rot ist
was ist das da vorne
ist noisegate vielleicht
ach keine ahnung also ähm wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten stream machs gut cu
ach so brauchen wir outro brauchen wir outro song
war das amd event nicht morgen
moment
doch doch doch moment moment moment das amd wartet mal das amd event ist morgen oder
aha excellent das gucken wir uns morgen zusammen an
das gucken wir uns morgen an
also chat bis denn machs gut cu